rappelé que le bureau de notre
commission denquête avait initialement
conçu cette audition sur la forme de
tables rondes ainsi que je l'évoquais ce
matin alors que dans d'autres pays la
réponse à la crise a été incarné par un
personnage politique un médecin ou un
chercheur qui a réussi à entraîner la
population derrière ces recommandations
nous avons assisté en france à des
propos discordants qui ont beaucoup nui
au niveau de confiance de la population
à propos d'un virus inconnu les attentes
dans la science était très élevé certes
la controverse est normale elle fait
avancer la science
mais quand elle s'étale aussi largement
dans les médias elle fait plutôt
augmenter le niveau d'inquiétude
nous avions donc souhaité demander des
explications aux scientifiques comme
certains n'ont pas manqué de nous le
rappeler mais nous ne lire nous
n'aurions pas nous ne sommes pas des
scientifiques de haut niveau et ce n'est
pas une conversation scientifique
cen'est pas à une conversation
scientifiques que nous convions nos
intervenants nous représentons des
personnes qui dans leur immense majorité
ne le sont pas davantage c'est pourquoi
nous aurions préféré préféré éviter les
monologues sans contradictoires
toutefois ainsi que vous l'avez rappelé
lors de votre audition à l'assemblée
professeur à propos du conseil
scientifique
vous n'êtes pas arriver à vous parler et
il nous est apparu que vous ne
parviendrez pas davantage dans cette
enceinte à parler en toute sérénité
cette audition a pour objet la recherche
les tests et les traitements elle
abordera notamment la méthodologie
applicable aux essais cliniques
les orientations privilégiées en france
au vu de la comparaison entre discovery
et recovery les résultats ci que la
question des publications ou d annonce
précoce dans la crise
donc je vais demander aux professeurs
out de présenter brièvement ses
principaux messages en 10 15 minutes
parce que les messages sont importants
et vous ne montrez pas bien sûrs d'eux
nous alimenter par voie écrite comme
vous l'avait déjà fait à différentes
occasions je demanderai ensuite chacun
des des rapporteurs d'intervenir et
ensuite ce seront nous des questions de
nos commissaires que nous regroupons
voilà alors avant c'est une commission
denquête donc je vais procéder à la
demande de deux prêté serment rappeler
que tout propos mensongers et punis
d'une peine pouvant aller jusqu'à cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé
donc professeur didier raoult ltte prêté
serment de dire la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je je merci bonjour appelle bien
sûr comme à chaque fois il est de mon
devoir que le port du masque est
obligatoire
je vous demande la plus grande vigilance
par le pour le garder tout au long des
heures de ses auditions de cet après
midi merci donc sans plus tarder écoutez
je vous cède la parole
je vous remercie et d'ailleurs je
voudrais profiter de cette offre merci
de l'inviter ici de cette occasion dans
lequel vous m'avez demandé de juré de
dire toute la vérité
pour vous expliquer pourquoi je ne peux
pas me retrouver à discuter avec des
gens qui font une tribune en disant que
je frotte dès que je triche en mettant
leurs noms et ensuite faire une
discussion avec ya une limite c'est plus
des discussions scientifiques en a
d'autres qui ont porté plainte auprès de
moi auprès du conseil de l'ordre et vous
comprendrez bien que mal et vite c'est
une des limites ma convivialité je
n'aime pas qu'on insulte je n'aime pas
qu'on porte plainte contre moi a qu'à
prendre demande de débattre en toute
sérénité
je le fais pas et donc je vous le dis
très solennellement et après avoir juré
de dire la vérité je n'ai jamais fraudé
de ma vie j'ai écrit 3500 publications
internationales
je n'en ai jamais rétracté aucune alors
bien entendu sur 3500 il y a eu des
erreurs qui sont passés pour l'instant
il ya une fille qui me traquent la une
chasseuse de têtes depuis que je suis
célèbre
qui a réussi à trouver cinq erreurs sur
3500 il y en a probablement beaucoup
plus que ça j'estime qu'il ya entre 2 et
4 % d'erreurs dans les papiers que j'ai
fait et donc je ne serais pas étonné
qu'on trouve d'autres erreurs mais je je
je dois vous dire que je ne suis qu'un
pauvre humain que je fais des erreurs
comme tout le monde mais de m'accuser
sur une tribune officiellement de fraude
de mettre son nom là dessus et de penser
que je vais débattre avec c'est au
dessus de mes forces et je vous demande
de me pardonner de ne pas avoir la force
de discuter sereinement avec des gens
qui m'insultent je ferai pas je ferai
jamais bien si vous si j'ai quelques
messages à passer dans cette affaire
c'est effectivement si vous voulez la
chose qui me frappe le plus depuis le
début et qui est lié au fait qu'il
manque quelque chose dans mon la forme
de mon cerveau je suis absolument
incapable de mesurer la dimension
symbolique des choses c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé n'est pas normal on n'est
plus en train de parler de chimie ou de
malades ou de médicaments on est en
train de parler de quelque chose qui est
déconnecté de ce que moi je connais moi
je suis un être très pragmatique et
pratique il ya toujours eu dans la
séance une grande différence entre
l'empirisme d'un côté c'est à dire
l'observation des phénomènes et leur
description si vous voulez et d'autre
part les théories déductive et
spéculative donc donc dont je ne suis
pas un praticien d'accord mais si vous
voulez ce qui s'est passé dans cette
situation est absolument inouïe pour moi
et pas que pour moi ça marquera tout
l'épistémologie histoire des sciences
c'est à dire que un des deux médicaments
les plus prescrits au monde ait pu être
considéré comme étant un truc qui tue et
10 % des gens est quelque chose qui
montre qu'il y avait une déconnexion
entre la perception de ce qui est
l'hydrochlorothiazide si vous voulez du
de la chimie de la molécule qui a été
utilisée c'est probablement deux
milliards de personnes
donc il y a quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas auquel je ne suis pas
censé pas de maintenant je me rends
compte que je ne comprends pas bien les
données symbolique
ou les c'est comme ça et donc je suis
extraordinairement surpris de l'ampleur
qu'a pris cette chose est immédiatement
c'est à dire dès que mon premier papier
a été envoyée la chasseuse de têtes l'a
fait dire que j'avais des conflits
d'intérêts avec sanofi ce qui est
complètement idiot je fais des essais
thérapeutiques pour personne ça fait 25
ans que je suis contre je fais pas la
deuxième chose est la demande
elle a fait de confirmer elle nous a
fait faire envoyer au journal qui
menaçait de le d'enlever cet article qui
est devenu le plus cité de toute la
littérature soit la thérapeutique nous
convient de 19,7 is it est de 1400 fois
en dix ans que je n'avais pas eu les
autorisations ge a pas eu de cdp et la
troisième chose déluge des gens qui sont
des maniaques de méthodologie je ne
pouvais pas imaginer qu'en envoyant un
papier comme ça comme j'en ai envoyé
tellement dans ma vie c'est vrai ceux ci
allaient faire une espèce de folie
mondiale et donc toutes les explications
on comprend données ne sont pas
inintéressantes c'est le temps qui
trahira pour comprendre ce qui s'est
passé
moi personnellement je ne comprends pas
c'est que ça ne fait pas partie de ce
que je suis capable de comprendre parce
que qui me manque une case sur la
signification symbolique des choses
peut-être pas que symbolique mais en
tout cas c'est à mon c'est pas mon
problème donc nous on a continué à faire
je pensais depuis longtemps
en réalité depuis plus de vingt ans je
pensais qu'il fallait faire comme pour
les centres anticancéreux des centres de
lutte pour les maladies infectieuses qui
comprenait tous les patients le
laboratoire la recherche
petit à petit je l'écris a 20 ans quand
j'étais le conseiller de de mattei et de
madame haigneré où j'ai rencontré
d'ailleurs gilles bloch donc qu'ils
connaissent et parfaitement mes projets
puisqu'il n'est entré au cabinet de
maintenant il est directeur d'unia
il était rentré au cabinet de mme à
l'améliorer en dix ans pour faire face à
des situations comme celle-là il faut
avoir des structures organisées dans
lequel on fasse tous des alliés des gens
qu'ils soient compétents à tous les
domaines et à tous les niveaux de
manière à pouvoir répondre à toutes les
questions au fur et à mesure et pas
avoir un ordre dispersé donc l' ordre
dispersé
monsieur le sénateur je savais qu'il
allait arriver
c'est pas moi qui les disperser nous
étions en ordre dispersé et d'une
manière très singulière pour pas que
vous croyez que je considère qu'à paris
plus rien est organisée c'est pas vrai
en neurologie si quelqu'un avait un
problème dans ma famille je l'enverrai à
la pitié parce qu'il ya un centre de
neurologie qui est comme ça s'il y avait
quelqu'un qui avait un problème
génétique que je l'enverrai sûrement à
necker et imagine pas de problème avec
ça mais en maladies infectieuses
ici on a détruit l'organisation des
maladies infectieuses
elle n'existe plus et donc si vous
retrouvez avec un pauvre marseillais en
train de vous dire ce qu'ils pensent
c'est parce qu'il ya une destruction
physique de l'organisation des maladies
infectieuses qui était à l'hôpital
claude bernard là les forces de maladies
infectieuses l'institut de veille
sanitaire a été mis à saint maurice
alors que c'était une vraie bonne idée
moi j'avais écrit à l'époque de le
mettre à côté pasteur ou de maître - des
antennes de pasteur à côté voyez le les
hôpitaux de maldic spécialisé en
maladies infectieuses ont été dispersées
dans toute la ville et donc vous n'avez
pas de sens vous n'avez pas de pardonnez
moi je vis y vous n'avez pas de patron
et si de maladies infectieuses vous
l'avez pas alors que vous l'aviez il ya
30 ans vous l'avez pas vous avez des
patrons dans les autres domaines vous
avez des gens qui sont des leaders dans
les autres domaines dans ce domaine là
vous n'avez pas de leader
vous n'avez plus de leaders
microbiologie celui qui était le
meilleur a été tellement dégoûté public
est parti en suisse
d'accord donc vous avez il ya un
problème ici avec les maladies
infectieuses
un véritable problème d'évolution l'asie
placer qui fait des choses absolument
remarquable s'est éloigné et petit à
petit avec le temps de la pratique les
maladies infectieuses à l'hôpital
pasteur donc quand j'étais jeune je
faisais tous les diagnostics l'institut
pasteur l'épidémiologie partout à la cdu
persuade petit à petit cette partie là a
disparu pour être remplacé par par des
parrains une recherche fondamentale
beaucoup en neurosciences sont parmi les
meilleurs du monde
donc je veux pas une critique de la
qualité de ce qui se passe
il ya une désorganisation qui est une
désorganisation de ce pays et qui se
voit ici pour ce sujet là je dis pas que
c'est vrai pour d'autres
si je trouve que bull pour la
microchirurgie je pense que j'en
strasbourg sont les meilleurs ce que je
pense mais globalement c'est ce que je
perçois bout j'ai toujours pensé que je
pas la chirurgie cardiaque à paris et
merveilleuse et elle continue à la
georges pompidou
c'est pas il y a un problème
d'organisation de fonds et celui des
maladies infectieuses vous savez que de
gaulle avait répondu à la cancérologie
en disant écoutez on va faire des
centres anticancéreux donc qui regroupe
à la fois la radiothérapie la
chimiothérapie la chirurgie la médecine
il marche de manière inégale mais ils
ont joué un rôle très important
là aussi en cancérologie le l'institut
gustave roussy est une chose
extraordinaire c'est un des meilleurs
centres au monde d'immunologie de
cancérologie donc sais c'est pas la
question
la question c'est que ce domaine n'est
pas organisé et que donc il ne peut
connaître des discordances moi j'ai
proposé de faire créer cette centre de
la nature de celui que j'ai fini par
réussir à construire marseille dans le
pays de manière à mailler le pays pour
pouvoir faire face à des crises
sanitaires qui n'arrêteront pas et notre
susceptibilité dans notre civilisation
aux crises sanitaires est très très
importante très très vive elle peut
désorganiser complètement la société
si nous ne sommes pas armés pour lutter
contre ces cellules sanitaire voilà donc
le sens général ce que je voulais dire
et puis ensuite on rentrera dans le
détail de ce que vous voudrez t merci
pour cette représentation de
l'infectiologie en france donc nous
allons rentrer dans le vif du sujet je
passe parole 1 catherine des roches
merci monsieur le président pensait pas
de question précise jean fait tomber mon
mot de l'année
donc merci au professeur raoul de nous
avoir déjà donné des réponses à nos
questions très en amont pour nous les
rapporteurs de de cette audition ce qui
a permis de de travail et les réponses
et et
et aussi de pouvoir compléter puisqu'on
a fait une audition dans le cadre
commission des affaires sociales que je
pilotais comme rapporteur de la branche
maladie où nous avions entendu des gens
n'ont pas en public mais où nous avions
déjà balayé un peu des sujets qui
correspondait à l'état de la situation
au mois deux mois de mai quand nous
l'avions nous l'avions fait moi j'avais
plusieurs questions la première qui est
plus d'ordre pratico pratique c'est
celle du parcours du patient
qu'est-ce qui depuis le début de la de
l'évolution de l'épidémie
comment est-elle parcours du patient en
février ou au début vous avez vu arriver
les premiers patients dans votre
institut
quelle est-elle parcours du patient tess
de traitement isolement est ce qu'il
s'est modifiée au fil du temps et
qu'elle est aujourd'hui le parcours d'un
patient qui vient qui vient vous
consulté à l'institut un institut
marseillais le deuxième point c'est
c'est quelque chose que j'ai posée
déjà ce matin au professeur delfraissy
même si luis nenê venu en fonction que
le 11 mars mais lorsque fin janvier la
ministre de la santé nous dit au vu de
vraisemblablement de modélisation de
l'inserm
il ya peu de risque que le virus arrive
arrive chez nous bon professeur de
français nous a dit qu'à l'époque il
s'intéresse à nous et nous un sujet mais
que en effet dès la mi-février lui même
avait senti que quelque chose se passait
quel est votre avis sur cette ces
modélisations qu'on peut faire dire cela
la ministre de la santé de l'époque
comment l'inserm a travaillé pour
arriver à ces conclusions si ce sont ces
conclusions qui ont été à l'origine de
de la vie et vous comment
au niveau de votre institut et de votre
habitude de ces maladies infectieuses
même si là on était sur un nouveau virus
vous quels étaient les alertes que vous
aviez sur quoi vous basez pour pour
avoir avoir ce degré de connaissance
qu'apparemment les autorités n'avaient
pas ça c'est le premier point
la deuxième question c'est sur les les
essais cliniques
c'est une question que j'ai évoqué ce
matin avec le professeur delfraissy
également c'était dans ces périodes de
crise sanitaire où les équipes
soignantes voit arriver des patients bon
pour certains en consultation mais pour
d'autres en réanimation en
hospitalisation et où il ya ce besoin
d'apporter une réponse rapide et
thérapeutique aux malades
comment que ça peut se concilier avec
cette exigence d'essais randomisés de
travaux scientifiques robuste pour voir
l'efficacité du traitement
mais s'il n'y a pas pour tous ces
patients qui ne rentreraient pas dans
les études ou dans les essais avec un
médicament testé
est-ce qu'il ya pas une perte de chance
pour tous ceux qui ne rentrent pas
danser dans ces cases là bon vous nous
avez dans la note
donnez votre avis un peu sur ces essais
les essais randomisés tels qu'ils sont
et pas forcément adapté à la situation
pandémique telle qu'elle est un donc
j'aimerais aussi vous entendre dessus
une question plus que plus large que
peut-être pas celles centrées sur le la
commission denquête mais qui nous
intéresse au sein la conscience d'avoir
social puisqu'on avait fait un rapport
sur l'accès à l'innovation et notamment
sur les essais cliniques
le comité de protection des personnes et
j'aimerais avoir votre façon assez
rapide
votre avis en effet ce que vous nous
avez dit un peu dans la note mais
résumer sur comment vous voyez-vous les
comités de protection des personnes qui
étaient au départ de protée des comités
de protection des personnes éthiques
et qu'est ce qui a pu faire que là on
est allé assez vite sur certains essais
et que et qu'habituellement on n'y
arrive pas merci vous répondait
directement
ses soeurs à chacun chacune des
rapporteurs sur le bouton rouge
voilà la manière dont nous travaillons
nous comme je voulais dit je ne suis pas
un homme de spéculations donc je suis
très empirique est très pratique
pragmatique c'est la nature elle me
réserve de très bonnes surprises je
serais content de ce qu'on a pu trouver
je pense que l'on peut découvrir
d'ailleurs que par l'observation et
l'empirisme où on peut confirmer par les
techniques méthodologiques mais on peut
pas découvrir ça fait l'objet de grands
grands débats épistémologiques donc la
manière dont nous travaillons d'abord
c'est que nous lisons toute la
littérature et donc si vous voulez moi
j'ai été frappée du fait si vous voyez
le staff que nous avons donc il ya une
vingtaine de gens qui sont au niveau
professeurs ou juste en dessous qui
travaillons ensemble chacun avec
beaucoup de domaines c'est pour ça que
je crois à ce que j'appelle les mid
recherche et non pas au réseau je crois
au nid de recherche et on se voit tous
les jours tous les jours tous les jours
de 8 heures du matin et on a un
pharmacien qui nous fait donc vous avez
vu vous voyez les applications de la mm
qu'est ce qui est vraiment est ce que
vraiment on applique là et même quand on
est médecin et la réponse c'est non
deuxièmement on a une spécialiste
d'hématologie co régulation qui fait la
bibliographie des de stomatologie
coagulation on a un super immunologiste
qui était un ancien directeur des
sciences de la vie du cnrs qui fouillent
vraiment au niveau moléculaire sur la
physiopathologie on un chimiste
bien sûr on a des infectiologues
virologues des microbiologistes et
chacun nous des épidémiologistes de très
très haut niveau dont celui qui a fait
toutes les enquêtes sont charles de
gaulle dont je vous reparlerai qui font
un travail de fond sur le suivi
permanent de la libye au graphique sur
ces domaines et à chaque fois qu'on a
une question quelqu'un creuse comme un
fou pour en tirer quelque chose ce qui
veut dire je vous en ai déjà dit ce
qu'on a déjà fait 54 publications
internationales qui sont ou publiez vous
acceptez ou en pré tri ndt
donc quand on s'est retrouvé face à la
situation on a fait comme d'habitude
c'est à dire qu'on a lues
tout ce qu'avait fait les seuls sachant
qu'ils étaient chinois et on a regardé
qu'est ce qu'ils font et qu'est ce
qu'ils disent
et puis on a regardé qu'est ce qui se
passe avec les autres coronavirus et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec le
premier épisode de sarce et au début moi
je vous assure j'ai téléphoné tout de
suite au ministère pour dire écoutez
voilà les médicaments qui marche sur le
cervin pourquoi regarde pas le cargo
side qui est un anti staphylococcique
qui est générique et qui coûtent rien
qui a été utilisé dans le sahara un en
corée qui a même eu un brevet un moment
qui a été déposé pour le traitement du
sahara avec ça deuxièmement la
chloroquine qui avait été montée je
rappelle que faut aussi un ordi en
arrière mais à l'époque il est le
traitement du sart et donc les premiers
résultats qui sont venues de chine
in vitro ont publié nordin un des
articles du groupe de journaux celles ci
sont très bons journaux c'était écouter
les deux médicaments qui marche la
chloroquine et roxy chloroquine d'une
part et d'autre part leur m10 sévir
c'est lui n'étaient pas disponibles sauf
avoir des accords avec gilead ou à
travailler sur des essais dans le cadre
de ce que voulait faire gilad que nous
voulions pas faire donc nous peu de
temps après les chinois ont commencé à
dire écoutez on a de manière
préliminaire nos premiers résultats il
ya 100 malades qu'on a traitées on voit
une amélioration clinique radiologique
et sur le portage virale c'est ça qu'on
a fait c'est à dire qu'on si vous voulez
le lit des gens vous disent que le
synthé mais l'idée que les choses vont
se dérouler en france ces cds qui n'a
pas lieu
c'est une pandémie ça se déroule partout
il ya tout le monde a une expérience
tout le monde a quelque chose à dire et
donc on doit regarder les premiers qui
ont subi le flux pour voir déjà il avait
décrit une quantité de choses dont nous
y compris des choses qu'on a découvert
un peu plus tardivement comme ce que ce
qu'ils appelaient les l'hypoxie heureuse
voulait c'est-à-dire le fait qu' il n'y
avait pas les signes respiratoires qu'on
a d'habitude dans les pneumonies et donc
ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que dès qu'on a
eu des cas on s'est mis à d'abord tout
de suite et je réponds à quelqu'un qui
me demandait pourquoi il ya une telle
l'at-elle délais dans la mise en place
des tests nous les tests dès que le
génome a été publié trois jours appelé
avons commandé les amorces pc donc
l'idée une des raisons du retard c'est
qu'il y avait ce que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'expliquer assemblée nationale c'est
qu'il y avait dans l'esprit des gens du
ministère qu'il y avait des centres
nationaux de référence quitte ce qui est
un rêve parce qu'il peut pas être un
centre national de référence pour des
maladies qui n'existent pas c'est pas
possible pas de samba sow de référence
et des gens qu'ils aient moins chez les
pneumonies
les gens qui faisaient les coronavirus
c'est pas eu du tout d'ailleurs c'est
quelqu'un qui est à caen d'accord donc
c'est les gens se sont dit mais c'est
nous les centres nationaux de référence
est donc au début moi j'ai eu ces
discussions on me disait écouter non
mais il faut les du cas positifs faut
que vous les envoyer au centre national
de référence mais tout le monde avait
que des séquences à sont là on avait le
génome qui est publié chinois trois
jours après et nous on avait commandé
les les allemandes qui va extrêmement
vite et brillantissime hambourg à a tout
de suite dit tout et voilà moi j'ai
testé une qpcr donc on avait nous
sélectionné trois gènes qu'on avait
commandé pour qu'elle en avait commandé
les témoins positif de on a commandé les
deux des allemands et puis ensuite quand
pasteur à présent étudier ça on a pris
les 6e en a pris tout ce qui existe et
puis on l'a testé on a regardé ce qui
est bien d'ailleurs pas ce que tu
entends avec la paix c'est peut-être une
question qui reviendra parfois il ya des
contaminations qui se font à la pca il
faut toujours avoir une deuxième cache
être une troisième pour être sûr de
confirmer les cas qui sont positifs pour
pas raconter des choses qui sont fausses
parce que il n'ya pas de laboratoire
dans lequel ça n'arrive pas qu'il ya une
contamination
c'est pas vrai ap c'est comme ça donc si
vous voulez le la manière dont nous
avons réagi nous si on regarde ce que
fait tout le monde on fait je m'excuse
de cet anglicisme du match marking c'est
à dire qu'on regarde ce qu'ils savent
faire
on fait pareil en les imitent mais c'est
comme ça que que la séance avance 9 fois
sur 10 bases de vie à imiter ceux qui
ont lu la première expérience on fait
parler donc on a au début on a fait
pareil très rapidement très rapidement
on a vu qu'on n'était pas sur la même
longueur d'onde parce que chaque fois
qu'on parlait de cette maladie on nous
parlait décès
et de et de cpp d'en savoir s'il fallait
les gens qui étaient contagieux le
remettre à leur faire un prélèvement
rhinopharyngé on tombait des nues
qu'est ce que vous nous raconter c'est
les gens ils sont revenus pour savoir
s'il avait ça on va pas la faire signer
un papier leur disons qu'ils sont
d'accord pour qu'on les tests pour
savoir s'ils ont le virus
soyez donc on était pape depuis le début
on n'est pas branché sur maman il ya
quelque chose qui m'échappe je suis pas
branché c'était et donc je les voyais
pas comme des sujets décès je vous le
dis probable est donc que je les vois
toujours pas comme des sujets décès et
j'ai suivi au fur et à mesure qu'il y
avait des données qui arrive et on les a
suivis
le premier patient qu'on a eu le
deuxième arrêté c'est sa femme qui était
la première mais le premier patient
qu'on a eu et était quelqu'un qui qui
nous a qui nous a parlé de son anneau
demi si vous voulez quitter un sujet sur
lequel ont travaillé pour essayer
d'identifier quelles étaient les causes
d'infections respiratoires liés entre
eux un virus qui est parent fleurs et 3
qui donne des admis au printemps de
l'âne aux missionnaires
c'est par un influent et 3 donc ça nous
intéresse l'anneau demi donc on a repéré
l'anneau demi mais si vous ne la
cherchez pas et maintenant on sait qu'il
ya 60% des gens mais les gens n'ont pas
observé ça donc cette phase
d'observations empiriques et de lecture
de la delà de la littérature
vous voyez bien que dans les faits
discovery comme ça je ne parle pas de
pardon recovery des anglais je dis pas
du mal des français ils n'ont pas mis ce
critère clinique en disant on peut faire
du diagnostic clinique d'une maladie
infectieuse qui est pas frais il faut
faire des tests biologiques et donc ils
ont publié ça hein
donc il ya des gens qui ont publié des
séries qui servent actuellement à
réfléchir chez des gens qui n'ont pas eu
de confirmation diagnostic et même
l'élément clinique le plus déterminant
de tous il le connaissait pas qui était
la nauze me aggasy d'accord qui a été
connue ultérieurement et nous je vous
assure vous fait un tri avec la noce mis
en musique il était incroyablement
fonctionnel ça marche très très bien on
l'a testé en particulier en a testé dans
le dans le personnel de soins si vous
voulez et là on a pu les interroger
avant de savoir s'il avait été
contaminée pas donc il ya une vraie
comprend
ça part très très bien pour les gens qui
en ont moins de 60 ans et un test
merveilleux de d'efficacité donc voilà
ce qu'on a fait et au fur à mesure que
le savoir s'est accumulée bien entendu
on a changé
on s'est rendu compte au bout d'un
certain moment qui avait pas ce que
c'était mal décrit au départ qu'il ya
des troubles de la coagulation très
important on a commencé c'est d'abord
les réanimateurs qui n'ont vu puis
ensuite nous on s'est rapidement mis à
anti coaguler les gens d'accord on s'est
rendu compte que les marqueurs de la
coagulation étaient des marqueurs de
pronostics extrêmement important après
il ya eu les premiers travaux qui sont
sortis de chine encore sur les autopsies
qui montrait que ce qu'on peut prenais
souvent pour des pneus openbet des
pneumonies en réalité c'était embolie
pulmonaire multiples et que c'était des
lésions d'infarctus du poumon et non pas
de pneumonie ce que l'on voyait les
chinois avaient publié aussi qu'il
fallait faire des scanners low dose sur
lequel je me suis déjà prononcé je pense
qu'on avait beaucoup de retard
ça fait partie des projets de nouveaux
gouvernements de d'acheter d'augmenter
de l'équipement on a besoin de plus
beaucoup plus de scanner un
sous-équipement absolument terrible dans
ce pays de scanners pour remplacer les
radios thorax par les scanners l'aude
aux internes
les chinois avaient publié que il y
avait au moins la moitié des gens qui
étaient dix à symptomatique ce qui est
une erreur c'est à dire sans signes
cliniques identifiable en particulier
respiratoires
si vous voulez qu'il y avait des lésions
pulmonaires au scanner on a confirmé sa
d'accord donc ça veut dire bien sûr la
prise en charge à 100 arrêt changé
puisque quand vous avez des gens qui
disent qu'il faut tester les gens
asymptomatiques mais asymptomatiques
savent de quel point de vue est-ce que
c'est asymptomatiques
parce que vous les gens ne sont pas
essoufflé apparemment ou est ce que vous
regardez la saturation en oxygène ce
qu'on fait systématiquement est ce que
vous regardez les scanners et donc vous
ne voyez pas la même chose bien entendu
la manière dont vous regardez les gens
va pas vous dire donc que si vous les
considérez comme la grippe
si vous voulez donc la déduction en fait
c'est comme la grippe c'est pas vrai
c'était une autre maladie pour le savoir
il faut prendre le temps il faut les
regarder quand il faut commencer on les
examine ne regarde regarde ce qui se
passe on regarde les examens on lit la
littérature de
on avait déjà eu 5000 cas quand ça nous
est arrivé dessus d'accord et à partir
de ça on définit une stratégie pav en
tout cas c'est ce que nous on a pensé
c'est ce que l'on a fait voilà le terme
en effectivement quand on a vu cette
situation nous on a décidé qu'il fallait
puisque nous ne savions pas qui c'est
qui allait avoir des lésions et pas des
lésions comme ça avait été décrit en
chine avant que ça commence en france à
eh bien on a décidé qu'on a dit il faut
tester les gens quand ils viennent
d'accord et on a commencé à tester les
gens quand ils venaient on a tout de
suite mis en place notre système de pcr
à très haut débit parce que vous savez
que les français ont été rapatriés du
yuan juste à côté de chez nous et donc
très rapidement on a commencé à tester
des centaines de des centaines de pcr et
donc on a on a fait ça voilà et donc au
fur et à mesure et bien on a augmenté 1
maintenant on a et on conseille aux gens
de mesurer leur saturation en oxygène
s'ils ont moins de 80 cas je pense qu'il
faut généraliser show qui viennent un
hôpital pour allant de l'oxygène parce
que sinon au moment où ils sentent
qu'ils sont insuffisants respiratoires
c'est juste avant de rentrer en réa et
même maintenant il ya même à marseille
il ya entre 50 et 60% des gens qui
rentrent en réanimation commencent leurs
soins en réanimation et cela on aurait
peut-être pu empêcher qu'ils rentrent en
réanimation les oxygen en avant les
anticoagulants avant voyez donc c'est
une notion qui est importante qu'on
pouvait pas connaître avant cette
discordance si vous voulez entre les
signes cliniques et l'état d'oxygénation
est d'ailleurs un de ceux qui est bon
pas mais plus jeune que 59 ans est mort
d'embolie pulmonaire
s'il était arrivé trois semaines plus
tard et c'est à mort parce qu'on savait
à ce moment là trois semaines plus tard
donc cette connaissance progressive si
vous voulez va mal avec des opinions
très tranchées initial et puis donc au
fur et à mesure du savoir nous avons
modifié les choses comme je voulais dire
on a fait on a proposé tout de suite
hein
une proposition des ces thérapeutiques
qui limitait ce qui avait été fait en
chine avec des posologies
avec lesquels on est familier
l'hydroxyde rocky et d'un essai
thérapeutique qui a toujours été avec un
seul bras donc a été validé par le cpp à
l'époque on a rajouté parce que c'est ça
fait partie de la pratique clinique de
l'asie trop missiles dont on savait par
ailleurs que c'était un antiviral sur
des virus à arn et on a eu la surprise
de voir que les charges virales diminué
à une vitesse absolument spectaculaire
donc on a dit oui mais voilà a prévenu
mme et tout de suite on a toujours tenu
au courant le ministère et on a voulu
faire un essai thérapeutique en disant
écoutez cette azithromycine c'est
tellement impressionnant qu'on veut
faire un groupe hydroxy chloroquine un
groupe l'hydroxyde chloroquine
azithromycine et là dans le cpp on est
tombé sur un méthodologie ce qu'ils
voulaient qu'on reparte à zéro et qu'on
fasse un groupe de placebo ce que moi je
pouvais pas faire parce que je considère
que ce n'est pas éthique ont joué par
faire et donc on a dit on va faire ce
que le soin courant et là l'état de la
connaissance nous permet de dire parce
qu'on venait de publier donc c'est ce
qu'on a fait et donc ensuite et bien au
fur et à mesure on a continué à avoir
une politique de cette nature compte
tenu du fait que les gens ont soulevé
quelque chose qui m'étonne sur ce qui
m'étonne toujours des reins sur le sur
la toxicité potentielle de l'hydroxyde
brooklyn on a rajouté pour pour être sûr
qu'il y avait aucun problème on a
demandé au professeur de cardiologie de
vérifier tous nos tous nos
électrocardiogramme
on a fait systématiquement des cahiers
mis à tout le monde pour être sûr et on
a installé dans les hacher la dosage du
potassium en moins d'une demi-heure pour
être sûr de pouvoir tout de suite dans
les traitements donc tout ça au fur à
mesure que les questions sont levés on a
réagi pragmatiquement parce qu'on a
cette autonomie cette capacité à faire
les choses sur place et décider au fur
et à mesure de les faire fonctionner et
puis voilà maintenant
soit les gens comme ça et puis je vous
ai donné tous ces chiffres sont
entièrement officiel aussi les chiffres
que je vous donne je peux pas inventer
chiffres je donne tout ça tous les jours
à la rs tous les morts tous les détecter
tous les positifs on peut pas inventer
des chiffres dans ce pays c'est c'est
l'assistance publique enfin c'est pas
peut pas inventer les chiffres c'est
donc il faut revenir sur terre gens qui
pensent qu'on invente les données mais
je ne sais pas si ça va tourner un pays
administrés parfois trop profond je vous
coupe parce que il y aura beaucoup de
questions catherine des roches avait
posé la question sur les cpp éthiques
oui moi je si vous voulez un avis j'ai
un avis qui est le mien est donc que je
veux bien partager vous vous savez je me
méfie peut-être parce que le temps a
passé je me méfie beaucoup de toutes les
modes
donc je suis pas très sensible non plus
à ça les modes méthodologique ce sont
des modes méthodologique
c'est je vais vous donner un exemple je
voulais donner parce que vous n'êtes pas
obligés de me croire mais je vous donne
les documents sur lesquels on va arriver
ce document je lui ai transmis c'est le
cochrane library
ils sont spécialisés peut-être 25 ans
pour analyser toutes les publications et
toutes les recommandations d'accord et
comme maintenant les recommandations
depuis qu'a été développé quelque chose
qui s'appelle la médecine basée sur les
évidences et de dire écoutez il faut
avoir un essai ou deux essais randomisés
donc là dessus et qu'ils ont étudiés et
eux c'est les rois de cette analyse là
et eux ils ont analysé 250 méta-analyse
ces analyses qui a regroupé plusieurs
années dans plus de 4000 analyse pour
regarder s'il y avait une différence de
résultats et de qualité entre les études
randomisées les études observationnelles
et la conclusion c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
différence
d'accord donc le fait que les études
randomisées et soit l'alpha et l'oméga
de la prise en charge thérapeutique
c'est juste parfait canton
recommandations aussi parce qu'au bout
d'un mois ces choses qui pour moi aller
de soi mais s'il faut que j'explique jeu
les explique
moi je regardais les recommandations de
la société américaine de maladies
infectieuses je vous ai donné la
référence avec quelqu'un qui a fait une
fois cette analyse en disant combien des
recommandations de la société américaine
de maladies infectieuses sont basés sur
au moins une étude randomisée à 18%
donc il ya 81 2% des recommandations
thérapeutiques en maladies infectieuses
aux états unis pour lequel il y à 0
étude randomisée d'accord donc il faut
être un peu plus paisible avec sa avant
de dire vous savez c'est la règle et
comme ça sinon vous tuer c'est nous qui
savons celle-ci de l'idéologie c'est une
des raisons sur lesquelles je ne veux
pas discuter de ça ce plan idéologique
je les fais déjà j'avais fait jeudi déjà
chuté à online où j'avais invité
costagliola pour parler des méthodes
nous n'étions pas d'accord parce que sur
le plan idéologique nous ne sommes pas
d'accord
maintenant nous ne sommes pas d'accord
non plus j'ai essayé de l'exprimer comme
médecin moi je ne veux pas faire ça sert
je ne peux pas à dire un malade
écoutez je vais vous donner un truc je
sais pas si un traitement ou pas dedans
et je vais vous tire au sort je sais pas
le faire
je n'ai jamais su le faire et je ne le
ferai pas et les malades qui accepte je
vous assure que 1 soit ils n'ont pas
compris soit la plupart refusent parce
qu'on n'est pas là pour ça d'accord et
donc il ya une vraie question qui est
est ce que on devient maniaque du
méthode si vous voulez qui manifestement
n'est pas réellement pratiqué très
fréquemment par des praticiens d'accord
ou est ce que on est dans le contrat
millénaire que nous avons deux je vais
faire du mieux que je peux avec ce que
je sais où ce que je crois savoir à ce
moment là pour vous spécifiquement et
donc il ya une vraie question et on a vu
pour revenir sur une question
précisément pour le cpp une dérive qui
s'est faite au début les cpp c'était
fait pour ça c'était fait pour attendez
vous n'avez pas faire de l'expérience
avec n'importe quoi donc il faut qu'il
ya des messages qui regardait donc on
est prévu des compositions de ces plages
parce qu'on appelle ses anciens jeux
excuse moi je les ai vus naître le le
dedans il était prévu qu'ils aient des
gens de sagesse dedans donc il fallait
qu'ils un prêtre un pasteur un rabbin
des gens qui aient la sagesse et le
recul pour dire écoutez il faut faire
attention est ce que c'est nécessaire
moi je peux vous dire j'ai créé dans
cette dans ce pays le premier comité
d'éthique animal en france d'accord
c'est vrai qu'on a eu des problèmes
terribles faculté de médecine j'étais en
charge de la recherche
je vous parle de 1989 et on a fait un
comité d'éthique pour dire écoutez
est-ce que ce truc est vraiment
nécessaire est ce que c'est d'avoir les
conditions de vie de mon est-ce que
c'est pas totalement inutile donc les
cpp c'est à ça que ça sert les cpp ça
sert à aller dans notre comité d'éthique
animal et on avait interdit les essais
sur les chiens des chats et les sages ce
qui simplifiait les rapports avec la
population environnante
les rongeurs donc il y a une vraie
question c'est les cpp s'est pas fait
s'il ya une prise de pouvoir par les
météorologistes c'est pas fait pour
valider la méthodologie c'est pour
savoir si ces mots rares
c'est ça que ça veut dire est ce que on
a le droit de faire ça dans cette
situation là et donc c'est des lives la
deux oui on a le droit de faire ça dans
cette situation là vous avez le droit de
faire de l'expérimentation dans cette
situation là es tu devenu une dérive
administrativo méthodologique qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec la raison pour
laquelle ça a été créée donc c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'effectivement il faut
s'emparer
j'espère enfin moi je pense que le
législateur doit s'emparer de cette
question de cette réflexion sur
l'expérimentation humaine en sachant
écouter la l'histoire de n'ouvrir avoir
un scpp pour d'autres pour faire un
écouvillon farrage et je pense que c'est
du délire voyez je pensais pas ça mieux
et je pense que deux en revanche de
faire des essais grande folie contre les
essais de non-infériorité et c'est une
ornière faille aux rites et c'est de
dire aux gens je passe en qui on peut
faire accepter de dire à jean on va
tester un médicament pour savoir s'il
est aussi bon que le traitement de
référence qui c'est qui peut faire ça
qu'ils aient quelques et la personne qui
va accepter une chose pareille ça il ya
dizaine décès de non-infériorité qui
sont faits tous les nouveaux médicaments
ils sont faits avec des essais de
non-infériorité parce qu'ils sont pas
meilleurs que les autres c'est pas vrai
on n'arrive pas à le démontrer donc si
vous voulez il ya une vraie réflexion de
fond avoir moral je pense qui est aussi
un des éléments probablement qui a fait
jaillir une telle
une telle un tel conflit c'était votre
deuxième question
voilà je crois que vous avez répondu aux
questions catherine oui s'il s'entend
bien
le parcours du patient qui arrive chez
vous est le même depuis depuis le début
et améliorer à la fois une amélioration
si vous voulez où on a acheté du coup
quand on s'est rendu compte qu'on ne
voyait pas les saturations on a acheté
les des appareils pour mesurer la
saturation à tous les gens qui se
présentaient d'accord et donc maintenant
à partir de 95 ont fait les radios en
fait c'est ça ça a changé le
l'anticoagulation systématique ça a
changé
voilà ce sont des choses qui ont changé
un an tout ça a changé au fur et mesure
bien sûr merci
sylvie bernier merci monsieur le
président le professeur j'aurai deux
questions la première concerne la
démocratie
depuis le début de ces auditions on a
beaucoup parlé de démocratie sanitaire
en quelque sorte qu auraient été oubliés
on a oublié de d'entendre les familles
non je trouve surtout oublier d'entendre
les patients je vais vous faire un petit
témoignage personnel qui est qui rejoint
celui de milliers de personnes j'ai été
malade vers le 15 mars à un moment où il
n'était pas possible d'être testé
puisque les tests s'étaient réservés aux
soignants et on nous faisait 10 est donc
de rester chez nous avec des boîte de
doliprane et à ce moment là les malades
devaient n'étaient en fait que des
chiffres
on recevait tous les jours le nombre de
morts le nombre de malades et on n'était
guère plus que ça et je veux dire qu'au
moment où vous avez lancé votre votre
essai vous a été le premier à nous
donner l'espoir
je vous en sais gré je tiens à le dire
ici jusqu'à vos travaux le seul espoir
qu'on avait c'était une boîte de
doliprane voilà alors en matière de
démocratie sanitaire ça c'est une chose
mais pour le coup aujourd'hui on a le
sentiment qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie
dans le monde de l'art
cherche alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est
la force de la pandémie qui explique ça
est ce que c'est la pression médiatique
ou est ce que c'est le fait comme vous
l'avez dit en préambule le fait qu'il
n'y a pas de patron qu'il n'est pas de
leader dans le monde des maladies
infectieuses
ma deuxième question portera sur le
virus vous avez déclaré récemment il
existe deux hypothèses particulièrement
plausible soit que l'épidémie
disparaisse complètement
soit que l'épidémie reprennent et
deviennent saisonnière comment ça peut
être un cas où l'autre merci je suis je
joue massiges très sensible à ce que
vous dites je vais vous dire la raison
pour laquelle en pratiquant en réalité
vous ça y est souvent c'est des
anecdotes ou des moments de vie qui
déclenche de tourner les choses je pense
que je les dis à 100 mais il se trouve
qu'une fois à 101 dimanche pour voir
comment les choses se passaient au
moment où elles grandissent et j'avais
une de nos assistantes qui est une fille
merveilleuse qui avait passé le week end
à qui était épuisée et elle était en
train de se disputer avec un papa qui
avait un gosse de trois mois dans les
bras qui avait un masque sur lui sur le
gosse et elle voulait pas le tester
parce que ça faisait pas partie des
critères qu'on s'était donné et donc ce
type dit écoutez moi je suis passé par
un aéroport amsterdam j'ai peur que mon
gosse aux ballades et je suis dit 'ça
suffit que vous fait découvrir au seyant
partir à tranquilliser les terrifier ça
ne changeait pas les choses on peut pas
c'est tellement de vies ils étaient
négatifs
on a appris après qu'à cet âge là
c'était la plupart du temps négatif mais
on peut pas laisser les gens sans leur
proposer ou leur donner mon avis et je
pense que d'être sur le terrain
vous voyez c'est la raison pour laquelle
je crois tellement honorée d'être sur le
terrain ça nous a fait changer notre
manière de percevoir les choses parce
que on s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose non seulement
effectivement les détecter d'abord pour
les rassurer pour leur dire s'il était
ou n'était pas positif
d'autre part pour les prendre en charge
donc sur le sur la question de
l'évolution
je ne sais pas je pondère toujours ce
que je dis en disant je vais je crois
pas au modèle je crois pas à l'après
diction tout ce par quoi moi j'arrive à
raisonner ces par analogie d'accord donc
je dis écouter ce qui a plus proche
passe comme ça peut-être que ça va se
passer comme ça c'est la seule chose que
je peux dire
donc vous savez qu'il ya si il y avait
six coronavirus avant en a quatre qui
sont saisonniers ils ont bien dû
commencer par être autre chose que
saisonniers comme la grippe je voulais
la première grippe au moins du xxème
siècle n'a pas du tout été saisonnières
la durée de l'année elle a commencé
l'été c'est la grippe espagnole secondes
et puis c'est devenu quelque chose qui
est rythmée et qui est plutôt par quand
il ya un nouveau variant qui est plutôt
effectivement saisonniers pour des
raisons qu'on comprend absolument pas
c'est pas le froid puisqu'il y en a dans
le sud en afrique pendant des années les
gens pensaient qu'il ait pas de départ
d'afrique parce qu'il pensait que ses
affluents bizarre ça veut dire de m
fredo l'affluence du froid donc ça a été
décrit voulait à la renaissance comme
étant une maladie qui était sous
l'influencé du froid bien sûr c'était
nous qui le décrivions en europe
et comme chez nous ces saisonniers au
moment où le froid arrive on pensait que
c'est une maladie liée au froid mais il
y en a autant dans les pays chauds même
plus et la zone important qu'il y en a
toute l'année et un peu plus pour
l'afrique que je connais un peu
l'afrique de l'ouest
il y en a plus pendant la saison des
pluies au contraire donc on connaît on
comprend pas bien ses rythmes
saisonniers mais chez nous c'est vrai
qu'il ya une saisonnalité
tous les virus respiratoires non pas la
même saisonnalité je vous parlais par
l'influencé 3 c'est le printemps et
l'automne
c'est pas l'hiver donc si par analogie
fort c'est à dire écoutez comment à quoi
ça va ressembler analogiquement le sar
ce premier hop ça il ya une pique et ça
s'est arrêté en juillet donc il ya plus
de cas du tout et on a plus depuis
d'accord les autres coronavirus qui
s'est passé c'est que il ya un moment
probablement on n'a pas su quand est ce
qu'on les a découvert un peu par hasard
les autres coronavirus endémique et bien
il ya probablement une diffusion qui
s'est fait un peu partout dans le monde
parce que lui est partout partout on
trouve en afrique on trouve partout voix
en chine et donc il le il s'est installé
maintenant durablement avec nous et il a
une épidémie mais au jeu
saisonnière avec quelques cas
sporadiques pendant le reste de l'année
et donc c'est les deux modèles que je
connais de coronavirus tant que demandé
écoutez voilà dans les modèles que je
connais c'est que là donc les chances
que ça ressemble au modèle qu'on connaît
déjà mais peut-être que sert à quelque
chose de totalement différent parce que
c'est une autre maladie une nouvelle
maladie et là en plus il est en train de
se passer les choses que moi j'avais pas
vu décrite en tout cas avec les
coronavirus et la vitesse de mutation
qu'il a actuellement et donc je ne sais
pas ce qu'il va devenir
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma première
question sur la démocratie dans le monde
la recherche qui à mon sens écoutez je
je je redoute que la recherche au pas du
tout démocratique
cc je pense que là la recherche des
clubs le sport de haut niveau c'est pas
démocratique
l'idée que c'est démocratique si vous
voulez alors dans les phases
stationnaire c'est un des grands grands
épistémologique historien des sciences
dit vous avez ya trois phases dans le
domaine de de la recherche dans un
domaine particulier
il ya une première phase qui est une
phase pionnière est dans la phase
pionnière sont des gens qui sont
audacieux qui brise les lignes qui sont
prêts à donner toute leur vie d'accord
c'est les pionniers et puis ensuite il
ya une phase de plateau si vous voulez
dans lequel qui est dite normale dans
lequel les choses avancent petit à petit
on rajoute un petit peu un petit peu un
petit peu c'est une phase dans lequel
qui devient collective
c'est ce qu'on appellerait la recherche
démocratique dans lequel et les études
multicentriques avec sept pays européens
chacun rajoute un petit bout ça c'est la
face du plateau au pays malheureusement
après la phase du déclin c'est à dire
que le chant s'épuiser puis un autre
chantier qui ne sais c'est comme ça et
c'est tout les épistémologie sont
observés çà c'est vrai il ya des phases
et quand vous êtes à une nouvelle phase
en particulier dans les phases de
découverte
le conflit sont confiants parce que et
c'est toute l'histoire comme ça si vous
lisez enfin moi je vous recommande de
lire les changer d'avis un livre
merveilleux de la tour qui s'appelle
guerre et paix des microbes
la fille de pasteur c'est génial voilà
les vraies oeuvres scientifique c'est
pas un roman
il y tous les journaux de l'époque tous
trouvent tous deux qui rapporte ça pour
voir comment pasteur a réussi avec des
en ayant des forces qui était à la fois
des forces politiques des alliés qui
étaient les hygiénistes comment s'est
passée l'idée du germe
ça a été un combat terrible vous savez
que la marque qui était notre inventeur
à nous de l'évolution a été condamné à
ne plus parler par un type qui était un
immense scientifique qui était cuvier
qui était à l'époque tout puissant
science et qu'il a réellement rendu muet
alors que c'était plus grands
scientifiques de l'évolution du monde
c'est c'est la vie c'est un sport de
combat
je m'excuse mon prochain livre s'appelle
la science est un sport de combat oui
merci vous avez par les professeurs
avant de donner la parole s'il ne veut
bien bernard jomier de de vitesse de
mutation
ce matin on nous a dit qu'il semblait
que le virus ne mute et pas je ne sais
pas qui a quoi moi je sais ce que j'ai
moi donc je pense qu'on fait plus de
séquences que n'importe qui ont fait
énormément de séquencer dans des
conditions d'ailleurs j'ai obligé de
faire venir les gens le week-end pour
pouvoir continuer à faire les séquences
donc on a fait à peu près 500 séquence
de virus depuis juillet parce qu on
était étonnés de voir la forme que
prenaient les cas cliniques et
l'épidémie depuis juillet elle
paraissait différentes donc on avait et
dès le départ on a trouvé un mutant
qu'on a appelée marseille qui est assez
online vous pouvez les regarder qui est
assez qui présentait plus de mutations
que ce qu'on avait l'habitude de voir
les 23 mutation par rapport aux la
souche de yuan
donc on pensait qu réellement et celui
là on a retracé sa source
c'est à dire on y est venu du maghreb
sur les bateaux et tous les premiers cas
ont été vraiment lié à ça et ensuite une
diffusion qui s'est passé dans
l'environnement on a eu 100 cas de ce
virus là actuellement ce virus-là à peu
près disparu depuis août et on pensait
que c'est lui qui avait plus le truc et
on a maintenant 7 mi temps
celui qui est le plus
celui qui est le plus actif actuellement
c'est sûr on a appelé katroun à 64,4 est
globalement si vous voulez si vous
regardez le nom mais vous voyez bien
qu'on peut pas parler de la même chose
moi je vous assure c'est des données je
viens de les écrire qu'à les regarder
son online parce que mon mais
effectivement c'est une deux au
traitement mais tout online maintenant
en particulier ed situé sur un pique
nique pour que tout le monde puisse en
profiter
si on regarde nous tous les virus que
nous avons eu jusqu'en mai et contre
regarde l'heure si vous regardez sur
notre site vous le verrez on a beaucoup
réfléchi pour leur présenter de manière
qui est visible sert sur un cercle
le degré de variation par rapport à la
souche initial
si vous regardez la différence entre les
différentes souches que nous avions par
rapport à la souche initial elle donnait
un cercle de diamètre x si vous regardez
maintenant ce que nous avons depuis
juillet ce ce diamètre a été multiplié
par dix c'est à dire la variabilité des
virus que nous avons maintenant les
virus que nous avons maintenant son
antre présente entre eux dix fois plus
de variations que les virus que nous
avions jusqu'en mai et c'est des
variations qui sont très intéressantes
parce que sont des variations convoi
dans la dégradation des génomes en
général c'est à dire c'est d'aider des
variations c'est qu'à quatre bases dans
les génétique
qui sont intéressés pour l'adn et pour
les virus à arn place d'un thé vous avez
eu et donc la dégradation de ces verrues
est une normalement et réparer parce que
la plupart du temps est délétère et donc
là ce convoi majoritairement c'est des
mutations de tv rue qui traduisent soit
l'effet d'une enzyme qui est bien connu
chez les humains qui s'appelle la peau
beck qui a l'habitude de couper les
virus donc peut-être qu'au fur et à
mesure que ce virus s'est répandu est
arrivée des formes qui qui qui qui
permettent la transformation de ces
verrues soit il est donc soit il se
passe quelque chose dans ce virus qui
permet ça mais ce que je peux vous dire
leur sens là aussi étudié peut-être que
delfraissy n'y a pas vu encore mais moi
je les ai vus parce qu'on a envoyé le
papier on a comparé 100 cas à partir de
juillet et sans qu'avant pour regarder
quel était le degré de leurs troubles de
coagulation et donc ils ont beaucoup
moins de troubles de coagulation
ils sont moins sévères et la mortalité
est plus faible
donc il se passe quelque chose avec ce
lyrisme qui en fait quelque chose de
différent voilà et donc moi je regrette
voyez que quand on vous dit ça mais moi
j'ai téléphoné au conseiller du ministre
pour lui dire et pour lui donner et
donner
donc la question que vous me posiez on
voit toutes les semaines je téléphone en
tant que dernière qui est le conseiller
du ministre pour lui dire écoute je vais
parler de ça voilà ce que nous avons si
vous le voulez les données vous les avez
donc je je je reste à l'intérieur d'une
démocratie où je partage mes résultats
mais je les partage ensuite avec la
planète entière sans cas permettez moi
d'insister parce que la sphère me semble
d'importance sans qu'à comparer prennent
avant et après -2 mais c'est suffisant
pour je sais pas ce que vous appelez une
vision globale moi non plus moi non plus
avec global board mais est ce suffisant
pour affirmer oui à mutation ah non mais
là où sexe quand on sera prêt la
mutation c'est rien n'avance pas la
mutation c'est un truc qu'on constate
dans le virus donc nous on a fait 550 de
génomes viraux d'accord donc là de
juillet août
c'est visible on voit à la place d'avoir
cette base
cette bague voix
on s'est rendu compte nouer d'autres que
l'on pouvait séquence est directement
les virus avec les nouvelles on peut
peut séquencer les virus maintenant
directement en dehors de sans avoir
besoin de cultiver que tu es beaucoup
mais pratiquement chez tous ceux qui ont
moins de 20 ct on peut avoir le virus
entier dans les huit heures qui suivent
le génome entier à 8 heures qui suivent
donc tu voulais de pratiquer des génomes
quand on a tous encore une fois c'est à
dire on a le prélèvement on voit que les
c'était son bas on peut les envoyer
on peut les envoyer en séquences et puis
on a nous un mécanisme d' analyse des
séquences qui nous permet de voir ça
voilà bien me le papier sur notre site
seulement nous regardons tout cela bien
sûr avec beaucoup d'intérêt bernard
jomier merci monsieur le président je
voudrais monsieur plan revenir sur votre
propos liminaires et parce que le
professeur à outils a répondu et je
voudrais lui expliquer quel était
l'intérêt de notre démarche qui était de
vouloir vous auditionnés en présence et
on débat avec d'autres spécialistes
d'autres personnalités ayant une
compétence éminentes comme la vôtre
c'est une méthode que nous utilisons
couramment dans cette commission enquête
pourquoi parce que et la discussion qui
vient d'avoir lieu le démontre
parfaitement vous pouvez avec un savoir
technique qui est incomparable aux
nôtres en la matière nous faire un
exposé pendant 10 minutes de virologie
pour nous expliquer que le virus semble
muté mais un autre virologue et milan le
professeur lina nous a expliqué et nous
a dit plusieurs fois que non le virus
n'avait pas muté et ça ça ne fait pas
beaucoup avancer notre compréhension
nous nous nous avons besoin nous ne
sommes pas dans des conflits ce n'est
pas notre méthode ici de mettre en scène
des matchs de catch et de générer du
conflit
c'est notre méthode de faire ressortir
les points qui font clivages et si pour
vous ça peut être pénible parce que
vous avez des conflits avec d'autres
collègues d'autres confrères qui sont
parfois effectivement virulent nous ce
n'est pas ce que nous ce n'est pas notre
jaillir ce n'est pas notre problème j'en
suis tout à fait désolé pour les uns et
les autres mais nous nous devons rendre
compte aux français aux personnes qui
résident sur notre territoire de ce qui
s'est passé et sur ces sujets
fondamentaux qui sont les vôtres la
recherche les tests le dépistage
vous faites partie des personnes qui
avaient une expertise et qui ont été en
désaccord avec d'autres et pouvoir vous
entendre vous répondre entre vous et
pour nous essentiel dans la construction
de notre représentation et notre
compréhension de ce qui se passe ce qui
s'est passé de ce qui se passe voilà
donc je vais pas poursuivre là dessus
mais comprenez juste que nous ne
souhaitions pas vous faire vivre un
moment pénible pour vous à titre
personnel je comprendre que ce n'est pas
agréable d'être poursuivi devant des
instances disciplinaires d'avoir des
procédures en justice mais nous nous
avons la nécessité de mener notre
travail dans les meilleures conditions
et très tranquillement professeurs avec
le respect que que je vous dois vous ne
nous aidez pas là dans notre tâche votre
exposé est certes très intéressant mais
ne nous ils ne mettent pas à progresser
de façon suffisante alors je veux en
venir à quelques à quelques quelques
questions ah non vous allez répondre
at-elle il en fait mary vous avez région
venir à quelques questionnements parce
que vous avez là la tension je dirais de
nous envoyer en préliminaire à cette
audition un document extrêmement complet
de réponse à notre question ce matin
nous débattions et nous l'avions fait au
rapporteur par le rapporteur
mais vous ne vous inquiétez pas cher que
les vous allez tout comprendre ce matin
nous avons eu une discussion et les
jours lors de deux sont présentes sur la
question des tests et de la lenteur
refait pas l'histoire du déploiement des
thèses dans notre pays et au printemps
quand nous étions en pleine vague
épidémique
nous voyons tous devant votre institut
des fils de personnes qui venaient pour
faire des têtes et vous pratiquiez
beaucoup de tests et dont le
document vous nous avez envoyé vous
dites j'ai fait deux cent mille nous
avons fait la chute deux cent mille
tests sur cent mille personnes alors est
ce que vous pourriez nous préciser ce
calendrier est comme manifestement vous
avez commencé à faire des tests en
nombre très rapidement comment avez vous
fait comment vous êtes vous procurer le
matériel nécessaire les réactifs et
c'est alors que ailleurs en france
bah on n'arrivait pas à faire de tel
donc manifestement vous avez réussi là
où là où on échoué plus tôt donc
j'aimerais que vous me préciser comment
vous avez procédé
la deuxième question c'est vous nous
avez dit quelque chose de très fort mais
nous vous nous avez dit il ya une
destruction physique de l'organisation
des maladies infectieuses
si j'ai bien compris à paris enfin en
ile-de-france mais j'aimerais que vous
précisiez qu'est ce que c'est que cette
destruction parce que il me semble mais
peut-être le démentir et vous alors j'ai
vu aussi qu'il ya des polémiques là
dessus mais il me semble que globalement
les patients qui ont été hospitalisés en
maladies infectieuses en ile de france
n'ont pas eu de perte de chance par
rapport à ceux qui ont été hospitalisés
en maladies infectieuses dans d'autres
régions donc qu'est-ce que cette
destruction physique dont vous avez
parlé j'ai compris que le fait d'avoir
scindé géographiquement mais j'imagine
des services des capacités mais
j'imagine que ça allait au delà puisque
la critique est très dur et puis enfin
dernier point que je ne souhaitais pas
soulevé parce que c'est pas l'obliger
exactement ici mais vous êtes vous êtes
revenu sur diderot xi chloroquine et
l'azithromycine et vous avez dans votre
exposé préliminaire expliqué un principe
qui me paraît très très sens celui du
benchmark vous regardez ce qu'il fallait
et rangez vous avez cité la chine et
l'important savoir qu'elle a qui là
qu'elle a accumulées aujourd'hui il
semblerait que la plupart des pays de
des états unis au japon la corée du sud
à l'allemagne en passant par la chine ne
recommande pas ce traitement là donc il
semblerait que la science a parlé et
c'est la liste des pays qui ont qu'ils
ne recommandent pas ou qui même
déconseillent l'utilisation
l'hydro xi chloroquine est extrêmement
longues jambes et j'ai cité juste
quelques pays et ça ce n'est pas un
jugement sûr c'est tout à fait sain de
d'entrée quand nouveaux problèmes
arrivent dans la recherche de
médicaments de traitement possible et de
ham tenter de trouver que ça pourrait
être efficace mais aujourd'hui comprenez
que nous qui sommes on va dire des
spectateurs engagés de cette question et
la prise en charge
on constate que dans le monde entier ce
traitement n'est plus utilisé donc est
ce que ça signifie que le monde entier
est aujourd'hui dans l'erreur oui merci
vous inquiétez pas vous allez pouvoir
répondre merci bernard de ces questions
donc je vous donne la parole professeurs
pour la réponse créé un donc je pense je
ne suis pas d'accord du tout avec vous
et bien sûr sur aucun des points le
premier point le premier point c'est que
la question est peinte et ce n'est pas
non mais si vous avez des affirmations
auxquelles je suis en total désaccord et
à 4,6 milliards de gens qui vivent dans
des pays dans lequel on vit dedans livre
xi chloroquine donc vous pouvez pas
liquidé ça comme ça je passe mon temps à
faire des méta-analyses rien que cette
semaine est sorti ce qui est de sortie
en arabie saoudite et en iran
il en sort à peu près dans tous les pays
du monde donc on ne peut pas dire ça
vous pouvez pas me dire à moi vous savez
mieux que moi ce que c'est que méta
analyse sur l'hydroxyde rockin vous avez
une opinion et vous voyez bien qu'il
n'est pas possible de ce réveillon c'est
le temps qu'il fait les opinions vous
savez encore une fois si vous aviez
demandé au départ à quoi sert la 14ème
mois je disais à partir de février à 14h
c'est un fantasme analogique avec la
quarantaine ça n'a pas de sens sur le
plan clinique c'est pas vrai d'accord il
ya d'ailleurs une une étude de méta
analyse qui fait partie du rapport que
je vous ai envoyés et que bien entendu
peut être distribué à tout le monde la
deuxième chose c'est que le temps encore
une fois fait le tri au début les gens
disaient ça ne sert à rien de faire des
tests
pourquoi ils n'ont pas fait des tests
par simple parce que les centres
nationaux de référence leur ont dit
écoutez c'est compliqué et difficile de
faire les tests et une fois que cet
embranchement était parti est
extrêmement difficile de revenir sur
sept en branche
extrêmement difficile et donc c'est pas
vrai qu'ils avaient pas les réactifs je
les dis je le redis puis je vous le
redis encore une fois si vous voulez les
laboratoires vétérinaires ont écrit à
peu près à tout le monde y compris au
conseil scientifique pour leur dire
qu'ils avaient à faire quoi 300 mille
tests et les autres n'auront pas répondu
nous on a répondu et on sent les
services d'accor donc vous ne pouvez pas
penser que dans une crise comme ça où il
ya des opinions différentes
vous avez par la magie du sénat faire
que les gens votent d'accord la fin
c'est le temps qui trient le temps pris
hélas la fin on voit ce qui s'est passé
d'accord c'est à la fin qu'on voit ce
qui s'est passé quand encore une fois à
la ligue roc cyclo qui n'est donc pour
les tests on a fait ce qu'on fait quand
on est en situation de crise c'est à
dire tous les jours on s'est débrouillé
nous mêmes on a fabriqué de quoi faire
430 mille tests nous mêmes chez nous
l'eau phillies est d'accord on s'est
organisé pour faire face ces
l'intendance qui a suivi la décision
c'est pas la tendance qui a commandé la
décision c'est comme ça qu'on a vu les
choses et c'est comme ça que je
continuerai à les voir quant à votre
opinion sur qui et qui ne donnent pas
heroes cycle rockin je vous assure je
viens d'avoir un papier accepté sur
lequel on a mis l'ensemble des pays qui
recommandait hydroxy chloroquine la
mortalité dans l'ensemble des pays qui a
gardé avec login et ça n'est pas ce que
vous dites donc je ne suis pas là donc
vous évitez vous émettez une opinion
scientifique et donc vous voyez je ne
suis pas de corps et donc que chacun
fasse son métier et les vaches seront
bien gardées et vous entendrez deux éco
et le temps triera à la fin on verra
bien si vous nous bien sûr c'est dans le
sais je sais pas encore dans le document
je crois c'est dans le dos et dans le
document bon c'est dans le document que
nous communiquons bien sûr l'ensemble de
nos conseillers parce que la lecture et
il est intéressant de nos commissaires
pardon monsieur le président je ne suis
pas dans un débat d'opinion je suis
rapporteur d'une je suis rapporteur
d'une commission denquête et professeurs
je vais vous citer une liste incomplète
d'ailleurs des pays qu actuellement dans
les autorités de santé des conseils
d'usagé de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
si ce que disent ces autorités est
inexact je veux bien l'entendre je veux
bien entendre votre opinion qui ne la
partage pas mais vous ne pouvez pas dire
que c'est une opinion de ma part aux usa
là ni h et lignes fixes diseases society
of america déconseillent l'utilisation
l'aude roxy chloroquine en grande
bretagne c'est déconseillé dans le monde
l'organisation mondiale de la santé de
demande de ne pas l'utiliser quelle que
soit la gravité l'italie des conseils la
belgique déconseille l'allemagne
déconseille le brésil le portugal la
chine le chinese center for disease
control and prevention estime que
l'utilisation doit être déconseillé
quelle que soit la gravité le japon
l'australie l'espagne le canada
l'european medicines agency pour
l'europe la suisse et la corée du sud
je n'aimais pas une opinion si ces
recommandations sont erronées je peux
l'entendre et jeu j'attends qu'on nous
l'expliquent mais je ne vais pas mené de
débats scientifiques avec vous ce n'est
pas le sujet je réfute simplement
professeur le fait que vous transformiez
ma question en un débat d'opinion entre
vous et moi je respecte votre opinion et
je vous aimez les recommandations d'un
pays concernés encore une fois je vous
recommande de vous verrez encore une
fois on a un papier dans lequel on
explique ça extrêmement précisément
sondés général vous savez pour pour
faire des généralités tour et qu'on est
d'accord c'est extrêmement simple moi je
peux vous dire aux états unis et
agissent un pays fédéral il ya un tiers
des états dans lequel hydroxy feront il
est recommandé il ya un tiers des états
dans lequel ils savent pas trop ce qu'il
faut faire et un tiers des états qui
suivent les recommandations de fossiles
c'est un pays fédéral
donc il n'ya pas d'homogénéité aux états
unis et compare même aux états unis à
des conflits les conflits autour de
l'hydroxyde de routine sont mondiaux il
compare même aux états unis état par
état
quelle est la mortalité et yoko vide par
rapport à la prescription ou non d'une
au dessus du rookie
pardon la liste oui oui vous les
regarderai la liste nous on a fait une
liste on a marqué chaque source
à chaque de chaque source d'où elle
vient comment elle fait comme on fait de
la séance donc vous vous le lirez vous
avez si vous souhaitez que je vous
enlever le voile près print je vous
enverrai n'y a pas de problème mais moi
je le fais il se trouve que c'est un
sujet sur lequel vous imaginez bien
qu'on travaille nous on a estimé qu'
avec 4,4 à 10,6 milliards de gens qui
vivaient dans les pays dans lequel ont
recommandé ou entre où on dit et vous
pouvez tuer l'allier doxique la routine
se voulait donc encore une fois donc ça
veut dire que ces débats qui sont des
débats scientifiques très bien nous on
l'a écrit il ya une liste une liste des
sources comme on a l'habitude de faire
et puis et puis voilà vous regarderez si
vous arrivez à les analyser
où vous les ferez analysés par quelqu'un
qui vous aidera à les analyser mais on
ne peut pas de manière péremptoire dire
écoutez tous ces pays là ne le font pas
elles ne l'ont pas fait c'est parce que
c'est pas mal ça n'est pas les élections
merci il y avait la question sur les
tests donc vous dites vous êtes s'est
constitué vous même vous avez fait
moi-même vovo vos tests pour arriver à
cenon et puis vous les avez eu au niveau
des laboratoires vétérinaires et ça ça
n'a pas été ça n'a pas été très
rapidement pris en compte sur le plan
national quoi un retard par rapport à
écouter madame ou non j'ai eu l'occasion
de dire au président qui m'a confirmé
quand j'ai revu que la pcr est une chose
extrêmement simple qui posait pas
beaucoup de problèmes et que tout le
monde était capable de faire comme on
voit maintenant et à l'époque il a été
surpris et quand il est revenu il m'a
dit écoutez c'est vrai vous avez été
premier à me dire ça on me disait que
c'est un truc très compliquée qui
pourrait être fait que dans les centres
de référence donc il est parti un
régulièrement
donc si vous voulez là encore je ne
crois pas que quand on soit dans une
situation comme ça parce que je me suis
déjà trouvé
si vous voulez on puisse avoir un débat
entre les gens qui nous c'est quand même
la chose la plus simple du monde parce
que nous on en faisait déjà les
dernières 150000 de pc et que l'adn
c'est l'adn
si vous voulez et puis les gens qui
disent non c'est très compliqué et c'est
très complexe et le temps qu'ils trient
et c'est pas ici et maintenant qu'on va
trier tous les éléments qui sont liées à
cette donnée pour l'autre question que
vous posez non il faut regarder les
morts vous voulez regarderai les morts
moi je les connais les morts je sais qui
est mort dans quelle ville dans quelles
régions et communes mort et combien de
jeunes qui sont en jeu le sait bien donc
je connais les résultats là aussi il
faut aller regarder les résultats et
regarder les otages et publié d'ailleurs
les résultats et c'est ceux de santé
publique france et pas les miens il faut
regarder bien il ya une mortelle
il ya une surmortalité ici et dans l'est
qui est tout à fait spécifique
il ya quelque chose de particulier avec
une vraie surmortalité et y compris dans
des tranches d'âge on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir une surmortalité donc si vous
voulez d'ailleurs si en pratique de ne
pas traiter pas des moustiques et les
gens c'était la même chose que quand on
les traite et diagnostic on saurait plus
dans merci les questions des rapporteurs
étant terminée j'invite maintenant nos
commissaires à poser des questions j'ai
déjà 3 3 6 6 3 noeuds aux inscriptions
donc je vais les prendre
quelques-uns par quelques-uns et vous
répondrais de façon collective en notant
après de façon groupée
merci davance martin livriez merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
professeur rappelle je vous rappelle
simplement que nous excusons être avoir
coupé martin que nous devons finir nos
travaux pour 17 17 heures voilà il est
16 heures 13 très bien que quelques
questions j'espère rapide
la première que je reprends le début de
cette pandémie on est dans une pandémie
arrive assez rapidement une controverse
scientifique qui prend toute la place au
niveau communication et presse et de
cette controverse on arrive même à un
combat scientifique je ne suis ni
médecin ni spécialiste et je suis avalé
par ce combat par cette inquiétude qui
naît entre nous tous parce qu'on ne
comprend pas tout et ça fait quatre
points que ce combat dur
perdure et continue et je me dis
qu'aujourd'hui il ya peut-être une
possibilité de s'en sortir mais là c'est
vous qui pouvez vraiment mais vous avez
déjà donné un élément de réponse tollé
en disant idéologiquement je ne peux pas
et pourtant je me pose la question
ce combat qui ne méritent pas je trouve
d'être pourrait s'arrêter si vous
décidiez vous parce que vous en avez la
capacité les moyens et aujourd'hui
malheureusement visiblement le les
patients puisqu'il est de plus en plus
de patients et de malades dans votre
département de faire justement ces
essais en double aveugle parce que
finalement on se dit je comprends votre
principe de dire pas de placebo pour les
parce que parce qu'il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas être soigné mais aujourd'hui
si vous avez raison si vous aviez raison
depuis le début combien de patients
n'ont pas été soignées parce que
finalement on a préféré l'idéologie à
une tentative dont je vous pose vraiment
cette question parce qu'elle me paraît
tellement importante aujourd'hui de se
dire si vous avez raison professeurs
c'est tellement important aujourd'hui si
vous avez raison à ce que l'idéologie
est supérieur à le fait d'avoir raison
donc voilà ma première question
la deuxième concerne directement cela
aussi c'est la communication est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la communication n'a pas
pris le pas sur le vrai travail
scientifique et sur ce besoin de
controverses qui était indispensable je
pense dans le monde scientifique mais
comme partout ailleurs et qu'aujourd'hui
on est plus dans la controverse dans le
combat et comment on sort de ce débat
pour avancer pour permettre au monde
entier s'en sortir parce que c'est un
sujet mondial c'est pas un sujet franco
français et bah écoutez ça sera tout
pour le moment parce que j'avais une
autre question mais je les ai perdus
merci président bonjour dessert je suis
sénateur des français établis hors de
france ou bénéficier d'une grande
renommée
une reconnaissance parmi les trois
millions et demi de français qui vivent
à l'étranger
je voulais vous poser une question cette
pandémie a débuté en asie à toucher à
peu près simultanément l'europe et
l'amérique du nord puis l'amérique
latine au mois d'avril du quai d'orsay
en passant par de nombreux experts des
projections catastrophique était annoncé
sur l'afrique
certains pays on avait même le nombre de
respirateurs je pense entre autres à
l'ethiopie par habib par centaines ou
par million d'habitants on avait le mali
on avait l'egypte et un certain nombre
de pays qui finalement n'ont pas connu
ces vagues aussi importante que dans
d'autres territoires
vous-même français de l'étranger vous
vous connaissez très bien l'afrique et
sénégal en particulier et j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi et comment vous
expliquez que cette catastrophe annoncée
n'a pas eu lieu et quel est votre
diagnostic et enfin une dernière
question très rapide avec plus de dix
mille cas en 24 heures ces derniers
temps on peut comprendre l'anxiété de la
société face à cette pandémie
si vous aviez trois recommandations à
faire quelle serait-elle
trois recommandations quelle serait-elle
et comment voyez vous l'évolution de
cette pandémie dans les deux mois qui
viennent puisque c'est là qu'on nous
annonce aussi selon les sources des avis
très divergents
merci merci roger karoutchi
le professeur moi je partage la dernière
question d'ailleurs de mon ami régnard
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait tous avoir un
peu votre opinion sur ce qui va se
passer au ce qui pourrait se passer dans
les semaines qui viennent
moi je voudrais poser deux questions
assez clair 1
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait que
les médecins libéraux que les médecins
tout court
beaucoup ont été bien souvent contraints
de ne pas appliquer votre traitement et
de ne pas pouvoir le prescrire à un
moment où dans le même temps les mêmes
autorités scientifiques affirmaient
qu'il n'y avait pas de traitement qu'il
n'y avait pas de médicaments et que dans
ses conséquences dans ces conditions les
gens comme disait ma collègue sylvie
vermeillet soit on leur disait vous
promets du doliprane
soit ils pouvaient avoir votre
traitement et si ça n'était pas ça il
n'y avait en tout cas au début rien est
ce que c'est normal dans en 2020 dans un
pays comme le nôtre de dire à des gens à
qui on dit vous êtes positif
vous restez chez vous priez et prenez du
doliprane
est ce que c'est normal ma deuxième
question ma deuxième question elle elle
est simple ce matin je disais au
professeur delfraissy
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour le conseil
scientifique pour chacun de ses membres
c'est pas le sujet mais la réalité elle
est quand même que l'autorité du conseil
scientifique ne semble pas toujours être
suivie par le gouvernement
ce qui veut dire que on a
institutionnalisé un débat sûrement
passionnant entre scientifiques médecins
dans les médias et ailleurs mais qui en
réalité extrêmement anxiogènes pour la
population est ce que dans ces
conditions là vous pensez que le conseil
scientifique tel que défini avec les
missions qui sont les siennes a encore
du sens aujourd'hui
olivier henno oui merci professeur pour
vos propos moi j'ai une question qui est
en prolongement avec le débat de ce
matin ce matin on nous a dit le système
de santé français n'était pas prêt alors
on a eu quelques explications un peu
complexe un peu flou parmi lesquels oui
mais un autre système de santé il est
trop curatif alors ma question elle
concerne votre que diagnostic par
rapport à notre système de santé
pourquoi nous n'étions pas prêts moi je
pense que ça n'est pas seulement une
question de moyens puisque notre pays
consacre un certain nombre de moyens à
son système de santé je pense que c'est
plus une question d'organisation et
d'ailleurs on nous a dit aussi que parmi
les pays qui étaient mieux préparés il y
avait l'allemagne et puis je m'interroge
aussi sur le fait que notre système
[Musique]
comme beaucoup de choses en france
d'ailleurs et souvent un peu trop
corporatistes et donc je voulais votre
diagnostic sur sur toutes ces questions
je vous remercie
ben oui professeur président merci de
questions très rapide parce que vous y
avez répondu en partie déjà
néanmoins je voudrais quelques
précisions sur la première il concerne
la relation à la chine
ce matin le professeur delfraissy au nom
du conseil scientifique nous disait que
les informations qu'il avait lui-même en
échange direct avec les chinois sous
l'oeil bienveillant de l' oms nous
faisait comprendre dans ses propos qu'il
n'avait qu'une confiance très très
réservé sur ce que les chinois nous
apportait aussi bien en termes
scientifiques cliniques et qu'il doutait
fort de beaucoup de leurs propos
quant à vous effectivement vous êtes
appuyé au départ quand vous avez lancé
le processus chloroquine en disant voilà
c'est peut-être la solution est
aujourd'hui moins regard assez pertinent
ni même assez globale pour juger de
l'efficacité ou non mais en tout cas
vous êtes appuyé sur les expertises
chinoise pour dire voilà en chine il ya
quelque chose qui marche et bien testons
le en france donc je voudrais savoir
quelle est en fait cette relation et
cette différence entre les apports du
conseil scientifique et puis ce que vous
vous avez décrété puis deuxièmement je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur la mutation
la mutation et les souches vous nous
dites
effectivement il ya de plus en plus de
souche en tout cas c'est ce que vous
constatez c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre dans votre exposé mais ce qui
fait les choux les souches
c'est les mutations du virus des
différentes souches de virus qu'on
rencontre elles proviennent de la
mutation du virus
qu'elles soient ou non plus pathogène
plus virulente mais en tout cas elles
viennent de là donc quand on voudrait
savoir simplement parce que tous les
gens qui nous écoutent c'est ce qu'ils
entendent à la radio ou à la télé le
virus mute il oui ou non parce que ce
matin on nous a dit non
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le professeur
j'ai une poignée à questions concernant
les essais thérapeutiques vous avez des
protocoles
alors est-ce que des hameaux de
connaissances vous avez évoqué la
bibliographie que vous avez faite
concernant les chinois mais est ce que
dans ce que vous préconisiez il ya eu
des études comparatives qui sera fait en
fonction de vos préconisations
parce que bon il ya des personnes qui
ont dit que ce n'est pas forcément
pertinent
donc est-ce que vous avez connaissance
de l'équipe qui aurait utilisé
conformément à vos recommandations
vos protocole la deuxième chose la
liberté de la liberté de prescrire a été
mise en cause dans notre pays alors
pensez vous qu'il ya eu des pertes de
change liées à cette liberté à cette
obstruction
la dernière chose revient alors sur un
concerne également les mutations
alors je voudrais savoir vous avez dit
qu'il y avait quand vous avez commandé
des binômes que vous avez
fait des séquençages il ya eu vous avez
eu et cette mutation
alors sur quoi portait ces mutations s
des mutations ou des permutations
d'acides aminés à quel niveau il y avait
ces mutations pour que ce sera un peu
plus clair pour tout le monde
je vous remercie mr si vous allez
répondre à cette première salve la
deuxième suivre pour les les premières
questions
si vous voulez je suis content que vous
me posez cette question mais je me
demande pourquoi vous la posez pas au
ministère la santé parce que ce n'était
pas compliqué parce qu'il ya des gens
qui adorent faire des essais pourquoi
ils ont pas fait un essai dans le cycle
à hockey night raw piscine contre
placebo combat donc globalement
globalement ce que vous voulez et c'est
une des reproches majeurs que j'ai fait
pour ce report ce conseil scientifique
c'est que tous les essais avaient été
décidés avant que la moindre réunion du
conseil scientifique
il était question que du raid m6 viré du
lopinavir jamais l'hydroxyde nothing qui
était le seul pour lequel on avait des
données préliminaires et qu' il n'y a
jamais eu d'organisation c'est le comité
scientifique n'a pas été c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je me suis mis
en retrait de ce conseil scientifique
ce conseil scientifique n'a jamais
piloté quoi que ce soit par recherche
locaux vides rien et donc qui sait qui a
apporté les données pour savoir que les
enfants n'étaient pas affectés c'est
nous toutes les données vous avez là ça
me fait ça m'amuse beaucoup que les gens
parlent de maintenant qui découvre que
les ct n'ont pas tous la même valeur
ça fait deux mois et demi qu'on l'a
écrit non quand même donc le débat il
est cette semaine
alors donc ça c'est des choses que le
pilotage de l'état aurait dû faire
aurait dû dire écoutez dites nous
quelles sont les limites du s'étaient
dites nous quelle est l'incidence des
différentes couches de populations dites
nous quelle est l'incidence chez les
patients symptomatiques et
asymptomatiques
ça c'est du pilotage d'accord et ce
pilotage
c'est le conseil scientifique et de
faire et je peux vous le dire j'ai écrit
très tôt en disant écoutez ce conseil
scientifique ne peut pas piloter une
recherche de crise
j'ai fait des propositions dont je me
suis au thé parce que je je
je pensais que je continue à penser je
suis plus utile à faire ça sur place
parce que les décisions prendre tous les
jours et que je me sens à tort ou à
raison capable de le faire mais j'ai
proposé des gens qui faisait des
centaines de milliers de pc r j'ai
proposé de toulouse et celui de créteil
j'ai proposé des gens qui connaissaient
parfaitement la pharmacopée la
pharmacologie j'aurais jamais validé
l'identique rouquine est un poison
mortel
donc il y avait des gens qui étaient
capables de mener une véritable
politique scientifique ce conseil
scientifique n'était pas fait de gens
qui étaient capables de mener une
politique scientifique donc je le dis je
exprimé au président de la république et
au premier ministre peut pas faire plus
ouais donc je regrette
effectivement il fallait faire une
politique très bien en disant écoutez
puisque c'est comme ça
vérifier ce que dit raul t-il à quelques
éléments près il commence à les traiter
comme ça fait long pour répondre à votre
question sur l'efficacité
oui avant que ce soit interdit dans les
ehpad nous avons commencé à faire une
étude qui est là aussi
online que pouvait regarder dans les
ehpad sur lequel nous avons une baisse
de 50 % de la mortalité dans les ehpad
dans lequel on a pu traiter les gens par
rapport aux environs on n'a pas pu le
traité si on est passé de 27 à 14 %
c'est nos données aussi il faut le
garder voilà puis il faut faire pareil
plutôt que dire elle n'est pas d'en
faire donc je je pense
et encore le temps et encore les malades
je pense que les gens qui se posent la
question moi je me pose pas la question
c'est pas à moi qu'il faut la poser la
question et non seulement je me la pose
pas mais là non plus il faut pas vivre
dans des mythes truc il ya un énorme
papier qui est sorti aux états unis
american journal of medicine qui
expliquent où est la place de
l'hydroxyde clos routine d'après eux en
particulier au départ du fait de son
rôle contre les facteurs qui entraînent
la coagulation la coagulation est en
partie due à la sécrétion d'auto
anticorps ces anticorps anti
phospholipides qui sont les mêmes
anticorps qu'on trouve dans le lupus et
c'est la raison pourquoi on donne à
l'est et roxy claudine dans le bus
donc tout ça sont des éléments là aussi
c'est intéressant de parler de science
donc ça c'est des éléments dont on à la
réalité maintenant vous parler de
communication en la communication
personnellement je pense j'ai toujours
pensé que la manière dont vous voyez les
choses on partait dans le mur c'est ce
que je pense
donc moi je n'ai fait que je n'ai jamais
porté d'opinion à part quand vous me le
demandez dans une situation officielle
sur la politique du gouvernement je n'ai
porté je n'ai fait que donner des
chiffres et les données que nous avions
et que nous étions les seuls à avoir
dans ce pays et parfois les seuls à
vendre
d'accord je les fais que ça donc et vous
les avez je suis désolé je pensais qu on
transmettra à tout le monde vous savez
jeu sans limites
quatre pages de résultats de ce que nous
faisons et qui officiait comme on peut
pas tricher avec sa enfin ses folies n'y
a qu'à les regarder
d'accord donc encore une fois équipe
usée
c'est vrai que cette même communication
que j'ai fait peut-être que vous trouvez
que les nuisibles mais il ya une
quantité de pays qu'ils ont utilisé
cette communication pour prendre des
mesures et pour prendre des mesures qui
ont été fonctionnelle moi j'ai des amis
en algérie je vous assure qu'ils
testaient plus que ce contest en france
à ce moment là d'accord parce qu'il
avait compris qu'il fallait rester
d'accord donc il y avait une faut pas me
sortir l'angleterre il est sorti des
papiers aux états unis et en angleterre
sur les meilleurs journaux du monde où
les gens affirmé qu'ils avaient que un
traitement marcher ou pas marcher sans
même avoir fait un test biologique
donc il ya un phénomène de déroute qui
n'est pas que français il ya un vrai
phénomène dedans qui est écoutée ou
est-ce qu'on va où est ce qu'on va
et pour revenir je m'excuse pour les
chinois étaient posées pour une autre
question pourquoi moi je pense que ça
dégénère les chinois sont actuellement
les seuls compétiteurs que nous ayons
sur la science que nous faisons sont
tous en extrême-orient
c'est taiwan c'est la chine et la corée
du sud c'est eux qui ont actuellement si
vous voulez savoir une infection
respiratoire
les plus grandes séries du monde sont
toutes là ils ont pris une approche
extrêmement pragmatique extrêmement
moderne et nous concurrents c'est à
chaque fois je peux vous dire des choses
on essaie de faire actuellement vers du
séquençage direct d'infection du cerveau
une affection du coeur
on est tous contents parce qu'on a un
truc qu'on commence à écrire le papier
il ya un papier qui a été publiée avant
nous par des chinois dans un journal
dont vous avez jamais entendu parler
mais on est du coup on n'est pas les
premiers ça nous aide beaucoup
donc si vous voulez les chinois
actuellement ont une stratégie
et comme moi j'ai vu et qui m'a relancé
à un moment où j'étais un peu découragé
pour y achètent quand j'ai vu ce qu'ils
ont fait à shanghai
et je vous assure fait une délégation
pour voir l'hôpital car à côté de
shanghai pour faire les maladies
infectieuses vous comprenez comment
voyez comment y soigne je peux vous dire
c'est pas un truc vous regardez vous
voulez vous n'avez même pas je m'excuse
de dire ça mais vous n'avez même pas
l'équivalent en maladies infectieuses de
ce qui est actuellement au sénégal au
mali ou au congo ici d'accord au sénégal
si vous allez à côté de l'aéroport du
sénégal scheme ou aps
là je peux vous dire payer par gilead
d'ailleurs un et un bâtiment
technologique dans lequel il ya un
niveau d'équipements de diagnostic et de
séquences qui est absolument inouïe
donc il ya une course technologique qui
s'est mise en avant dans lequel il ya
une partie ici pays qui n'a pas suivi et
l cette course technologique
elle se passe en annexe en extrême
orient pour pour ce qui se passe en
afrique
j'ai choisi lui pourquoi je sais jamais
un jeu c'est après dire et deuxièmement
je ne sais pas pourquoi ce qui se passe
en afrique espace en afrique alors il
est possible que en tout cas c'est ce
que disent beaucoup d'africains qui ont
travaillé possible que le fait qu'ils
prennent de la chloroquine
systématiquement et joue un rôle dans la
diffusion de la maladie c'est possible
honnêtement j'en sais rien je ne
miserais pas là dessus c'est une
constatation qu'on peut faire si on
généralise à al usage ou pas c'est comme
ça concernant l'anxiété
moi je veux bien répondre à ça ça
m'intéresse beaucoup il ya peu vous
admettrez que l'anxiété les pas de mon
côté g c'est pas moi qui affole les
populations non seulement je la vole pas
les populations mais qui plus est il n'y
a pas vraiment de raison d'être affolés
et depuis le début parce que je vous
conseille de regarder les données de
l'ined d'accord l'ined c'est l'institut
national de la démographie fait donc
venir quelqu'un de l'ined si vous voulez
et vous dire à quelle est actuellement
la perte d'espérance de vie pas la
mortalité parce que la mortalité à 85
ans c'est pas la mortalité des accidents
de la route
donc la perte d'espérance de vie n'est
pas la même quand vous avez une
polypathologies que vous avez un cancer
métastasé ou quand vous avez 92 ans
n'est pas la même que quand vous avez 18
ans et que
vous avez un accident de moto c'est pas
la même d'accord donc ça se calcule
l'espérance de vie est la perte
d'espérance de vie actuellement calculé
pour 2020 comparé à 2019 et les deux 02
ans elle est inférieure à celle de la
perte d'espérance de vie de 2015
d'accord c'est ça la situation donc
c'est ça c'est énorme
anxiété monstrueux c'est pas moi qui la
développe un mois et au contraire j'ai
toujours essayé d'être optimiste et au
contraire d'être du côté de se dire
écoutez on n'est pas face à un drame
absolument insupportable donc à la fin
là aussi c'est pour ça que c'est pas
maintenant que ça va se régler ça parte
dans un débat que ça ça glisse ça va se
régler avec les chiffres à la fin et on
verra bien les chiffres et on verra bien
les chiffres donc moi je les vois
maintenant les chiffres je les suis gelé
une manière très précise parce que ça
m'intéresse aujourd'hui je suis
empirique
donc ça m'intéresse de regard des
données chiffrées que les analyses et
les comprend et pourquoi la grippe qui a
tellement tu es dans l'année 2015 bon
sens n'est fichu et pourquoi et qui a
tué plus que ce que ça va tuer installé
sauf s'il se passe des choses absolument
imprévisible pour moi pourquoi baisse et
parce que d'un coup c'était la terreur
que tout le monde attendait que qui
allait arriver
c'est comme ça moi j'ai essayé là aussi
vous donner des données comparatives par
rapport au désastre du passé c'est pas
le même désastre pour une simple raison
c'est que effectivement c'est pas le
même c'est a le même âge qui meurt donc
jeudi à 50% des gens qui y sont morts
qui avait plus de 85 ans et 72 % je
crois qu'ils avaient plus de 80 ans et
donc dans les pays européens
plus de 90 % avaient plus de 60 ans donc
que ce qui s'est passé c'est tous les
ans les gens qui sont sur un équilibre
précaire les les circonstances font que
eh bien ces gens qui ont un équilibre
précaire ton du côté du bo et côté des
choses et donc c'est ça que nous voyons
essentiellement est là depuis les
épisodes où je vais donner tous les
morts qui sont produits depuis trois
mois sur ce ces données là vous voyez
donc vous voyez les données d'âge là
chez nous je vous dis le le plus
le le mort le plus jeunes jusqu'à la
côte d'or avait 58 ans malheureusement
étant donné l'état peut absolument
épouvantable hockey qui est venue mourir
qui avait 54 ans qui a été refusée en
réanimation en état physiologique de
base était trop mauvais mais globalement
si vous voulez la perte et on n'a pas
calculé
il ya des calculs très complet qui
s'appelle les dalits qui rajoute les
polypathologies à l'âge et la perte de
2,2 d'espérance de vie va être
extrêmement mineure à la fin d'année
donc c'est pas moi qui développe
l'inquiéter je les dis encore la semaine
dernière
donc c'est pas moi qui développe
l'anxiété donc que le l'interdiction
prescrire tout le monde c'est mon
opinion dessus si vous voulez mais là
encore je vois pas comment on aurait pu
avoir un débat serein quand en espace de
2 d'une demi journée
on sait le ministère et le msc mis à
dire on interdit partout l'hydroxyde
eurokin parce que ça tue les gens pour
un papier qui a été retiré trois
semaines après parce que c'était une
bande de pieds nickelés qui avait écrit
ce truc dont personne ne savait d'où il
sortait donc c'est pas moi qui raconte
des bêtises quand même faire au bout
d'un moment il faut revenir sur terre
c'est pas moi car pour des bêtises qu'on
puisse penser qu'on puisse avoir la
pensée que ce truc est vrai quand on
parle d'un médicament qui a été donné à
deux milliards d'habitants ça veut dire
qu'au bout d'un moment on a des
connexions des deux parties de son
cerveau qui en a une qui est devenue
guerrière et symbolique
et puis l'autre qui est resté
pragmatique ou pas mais c'est pas les
mêmes parties d'accord il ya quand même
pour réussir à vous faire avaler un truc
comme ça il en faut quand même je
m'excuse mais tous ceux qui ont cru un
truc pareil c'est quand même
spectaculaire et pourquoi les africains
se foutait de leur gueule quand même
c'est parce qu'ils sont en train de nous
dire qu'on attend tous en train de
mourir alors moi de la chloroquine j'en
bouffe et à l'âge de 2 ans remet
africains on avait ça sur la table tout
le monde vous fait son comprimé plan
hockey peut-être pour ça que je crains
pas la chloroquine donc le attendez je
vais tout marqué après qu'est ce qui
m'amuse 1 qu'est ce qui marche pas dans
notre système de santé la hausse il faut
regarder les données chiffrées ce que je
vous suggère il ya un truc qui est très
bien fait qu'ils appellent
elle cette glande d'enquêté publié par
l' ocde tous les ans d'accord et c'est
très bien il faut regarder c'est pas moi
donc le chiffre faut les regarder et
vous regarderez quelles sont les
différences qu'il existe entre la france
et les autres pays en termes de
mortalité en termes de d'efforts
financiers
donc il ya un effort financier
considérable de la france la france est
un des pays qui met le plus d'argent
possible dans la santé mais c'est un de
ceux qui a le moins de médecins qui a
les médecins les plus vieux et ça c'est
l'état qui a voulu sa limitation par le
numerus clausus pendant trente ans c'est
pas ce gouvernement c'est l'état qui a
voulu ça donc il a limité le nombre de
médecins d'une manière drastique
maintenant nous avons les médecins les
plus vieux d'europe en fait partie nous
n'avons pas assez de médecins
les médecins hospitaliers gagnent moins
d'argent
c'est pas le cas des universitaires
double salaire mais de bien notre vie
mais les médecins hospitaliers sont
moins bien payés en moyenne en france
que s'ils sont payés dans les autres
pays ocde que dans la moyenne de l'oscd
eu d'accord le niveau d'équipement en
france est inférieur à celui de la
moyenne des pays de l'osce et des eaux
des grands équipements d'accord et donc
vous avez la question vous avez la
réponse
moi je veux pas débattre de sa non plus
il ya les chiffres il ya qu'à les
regarder c'est c'est vous pouvez le
télécharger sur internet s'appelle human
health and drugs tous les angles ocde
publiées les données chiffrées qui leur
sont transmises
comme pour la mortalité si vous voulez
savoir la mortalité vous regardez oromo
monge désole un nom un peu ridicule
s'appelle romo s'est toutes les données
de tous les pays européens de mortalité
au fil de l'eau donc c'est suffit de les
regarder
est ce qu'il manque quelque chose sur
les mutations donc vous avez des
précisions demandées par les mutations
je viens sur des virus à tous mute tout
le temps c'est comme ça à chaque fois on
était imitation c'est lié au fait que
vous faites une copie de quelque chose
et que vous faites une copie ya des
erreurs d'accord mais les copies de
l'adn il ya assez peu d'erreurs
en moyenne il ya une erreur par millions
de copies donc sur un million de base
datés gc dans la 1 million qui
présentent une mutation dans notre
génome dans ceux des bactéries la rn là
c'est un virus à arn
il ya cent fois plus de mutations une
pour 10000
pour une pour 20 me vous 30 mx a été
estimé ces estimés en général et pour ce
virus là ce estimé être un pur tant
mieux donc ces votations l'a parfois
sont des mutations dont on voit pas
qu'on appelle synonyme c'est-à-dire
qu'elle n'entraîne pas un changement
d'acides aminés ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'elle ne change pas des domaines de la
science actuelle c'est que parfois ça
change pas d'acides aminés mais ça
change la soie appelle la fitness et la
capacité de se multiplier du virus
parfois ça change un incident les
mutations qu'on a observé il y en a
quelques-unes qui se trouve dans la
protéine spike dont vous avez beaucoup
entendu parler et qui est une des
molécules qui fermement la spécificité
de ces cons à virus
il ya des ddd mutation qui se trouve
dans la nucléocapside c'est à dire dans
le premier anti essais les deux grands
antigènes vous voulez que nous
reconnaissons quand on a une réponse
immunitaire c'est un la numéro
nucléocapside mais qui est qui et qui a
beaucoup de points communs avec tous les
autres coronavirus c'est pour ça qu'il
ya des réactions croisées peut-être dé
protection croisée
et puis la protéine spike qui est
relativement spécifiques là aussi
tentant dans lequel on la mutation donc
ce que nous ont conté ce qu'on regarde
c'est le nombre de mutations qui sont
survenues par rapport à virus souche
d'accord donc bien sûr il ya des
mutations mais globalement on avait
l'habitude qui est en moyenne 9 à 10
mutation par rapport au virus souche
pendant la première partie c'est à dire
qu'ils allaient dans les souches que
nous avons eu entre mars et mai d'accord
dans cette deuxième partie le nombre de
mutations par souche par rapport à la
mutation mer par rapport à la souche mer
et divo plus à vendre il ya beaucoup
plus de mutations que ce que nous
envoyons avant et ça il ya plusieurs
clauses qui sont comme ça et qu'ils ont
donc une distance on mesure la distance
en regardant le nombre de mutations par
rapport à la souche primaires si vous
voulez donc ça veut dire que la distance
par rapport à ceux exprimés avec plus
importante maintenant que ce qu'elle
était merci pour ces précisions alors on
va
continuez et sinon d'être concis dans
les questions et les réponses néanmoins
il ya une réponse que vous n'avez pas
fait c'est concernant les préconisations
du comité scientifique qui n'était pas
suivie par le gouvernement si vous avez
en quelques mots quelque chose à dire
pour répondre à roger karoutchi
je me suis plus qu'elle était il ya eu
des oui il ya eu quelques
recommandations qui n'ont pas été suivis
on l'avait vu au moment des écoles on
l'a vu encore dernièrement où il la
question est extrêmement sa mesure le
conseil scientifique affirme enfin firme
est normalement l'autorité de référence
qui donne des avis parfois le
gouvernement suive parfois le
gouvernement ne suis pas est ce que
aujourd'hui l'existence du conseil
scientifique a encore une vraie valeur
dans le débat rapidement je suis
d'accord pour le fait que le
gouvernement décide sur votation parce
que la responsabilité politique mais on
voit bien stabilité politique après donc
la responsabilité politique c'est la
responsabilité politique c'est la
responsabilité politique c'est celui qui
a la responsabilité qui décide c'est
comme ça que je vois les choses
après il a des conseils que ces conseils
soient personnellement je n'étais pas
d'avis que les conseils du conseil
scientifique son public je pense qu'ils
auraient dû avoir un conseil du
président ou un conseil des ministres
que ça se décide au tour du ministre et
que le ministre disent écoutez voilà
j'ai écouté voilà mon opinion est que
chaud sorte comme ça c'était mon avis et
jusqu'à présent c'est toujours comme ça
que ça s'est passé mais la composition
du conseil dans une partie qui était
stratégique
à mon sens n'était pas bonne parce que
c'était le dérivé de reacting qui était
le groupe qui avait été mis en place par
les termes ça c'est mon opinion
alors on y va toujours le plus court
possible il nous reste un bon quart
d'heure
petit carnet angèle préville
merci monsieur le président donc mon
professeur j'ai d'abord une question qui
vient à la suite de ce que vous venez de
vous dire sur la mutation du virus donc
il y à des mutations mais je pense que
dans l'inconscient collectif
on parle de mutation quand le virus
devient beaucoup plus dangereux pas on
sous-entend que alors est ce que dans
tous ces mutations est ce que dans l'eau
cure les occurrences vous voyez arriver
par les connaissances que vous avez qu à
un moment donné il risque de devenir
beaucoup plus virulent c'est à dire
beaucoup plus dangereux
deuxième question alors sur les essais
alors vous avez évoqué les raisons
éthiques voire morale qui font que vous
n'avez pas voulu avoir recours à des
placebos parce qu'on était en k2 dans
une période de crise avec une maladie
très grave puisqu'elle peut provoquer
des décès alors est ce que il vous
semble
est ce qu'il ya des choses là dessus sur
le fait que quand on est en crise
on fait pas de décès visiblement parce
que effectivement les arguments que vous
avez peuvent s'entendre
et puis parce que on a souvent dit que
l'effet placebo c'est l homéopathie et
cetera donc pour des choses pour des de
la petite bobologie peut-être alors
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
l'effet placebo parce que peut-être ce
serait intéressant de savoir après une
autre question
vous avez évoqué la création de centres
anti infectieux est ce que votre est-ce
que vous sous-entendez que votre
structure à marseille en est une est ce
qu'il y manque quelque chose
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres sur le
territoire est ce qu'il ya des
équivalents ailleurs et est ce que vous
avez entendre été entendus par les
pouvoirs publics pour pouvoir après la
crise
développer des centres comme le vôtre
jour merde j'ai vu ni guillotin oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
professeur avant toute chose je voudrais
quand même exprimé un regret
effectivement de ne pas pouvoir avoir
avoir été auditionnée sur un système de
tables rondes et je m'en suis exprimé
auprès du président je pense que ça
aurait été à mon sens plus éclairant
puisque vous êtes un scientifique qui
parle à des scientifiques et ça nous
aurait permis de peut-être d'avoir eu
des idées un peu plus clair ensuite je
voudrais rebondir sur le tout début de
vos propos vous avez exprimé le fait de
dire je ne comprends pas je comprends
pas ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ça s'est
emballée médiatiquement quand j'ai parlé
etc
c'est ce que vous avez dit au début de
vos propos liminaire c'est ça que je
parte pas voilà moi je voudrais vous
dire que je vais vous donner mon
expérience personnelle je vous dire que
je pense comprendre
moi je n'ai pas compris par contre le
premier matin ou en fait vous êtes
intervenu sur les ondes nom de radio où
vous avez affirmé à ce moment là
effectivement les faits positive la
chloroquine et avoir suscité un espoir
en fait important chez des habitants des
français qui étaient à ce moment-là
inquiet en pleine période d'épidémie est
dans une situation une situation quasi
catastrophique d'un autre pays donc
votre vous faites votre expression
publique de votre statut de chercheur
reconnu et de renom a effectivement
suscité un grand espoir
or ne pensez vous pas qu'à ce moment là
alors vous n'êtes ni journaliste ni
politique vous êtes vraiment un
scientifique que l'on écoute reconnu et
sur lequel on pose en fait nos oreilles
et notre conviction
ne pensez vous pas que vos paroles à ce
moment là n'aurait pas dû tel être peut
être différée est ce que vous pensez pas
que les études auraient dû être un peu
plus avancé des résultats plus concrets
avant avant de douala d'aller confirmer
ou infirmer des choses comme ça qui ont
été prises chez une partie de nos
concitoyens comme d'un peu d'argent
comptant et je pense que ça a été le
début de la fracture d'opinion dans
notre pays est un espèce de deux clans
en fait dans ce pays les pour et les
contre le professeur à août alors que le
débat et je le conçois n'est absolument
pas là donc c'est un petit peu
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une forme d'
imprudence ou est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pensé que c'était la bonne solution et
que vous recommenceriez avec
l'expérience ce même cette même
expression publique et après j'avais
deux autres questions mais ça a été
répondu pourquoi ne pas avoir fait les
études en double aveugle mais ça rejoint
la première est enfin là que la question
de la mutation est ce que la mutation
que vous exprimer en laboratoire est une
mutation clinique avec plus grand plus
de gravité ou au contraire une gravité
moins importante
et puis un changement de cible voilà
mais la question a été posée donc je
n'irai pas plus loin je vous remercie
merci merci céline boulay merci monsieur
le président j'étais vraiment venu à
cette audition m'a aussi pour poser la
question qui rejoint celle de sujets
vers millet de ma collègue à l'instant
qui était de dire que dit de vous
finalement cette sur médiatisation et
cet emballement médiatique
et qu'est ce que ça dit du débat
contradictoire en france et de la
démocratie sanitaire
vous avez partiellement répondu et
notamment répondu avec une certaine
modestie je le trouve en tout cas
personnellement tout au long de cette
audition en faisant l'apologie de
l'empirisme et en disant on attend un
peu on va comparer les chiffres et là on
verra qui aura raison il vous avait
parlé de pionnier en la matière en tout
cas puisqu'il s'agit souvent nord de nos
auditions de retour d'expérience je note
qu'il ya une grande confusion qui règne
dans la tête de nos compatriotes
français puisque en attendant les
chiffres est de savoir qui aura raison
le retour d'expérience qui était censée
rassurer tout le monde en disant on a
vécu une première crise majeure
on saura qui on saura gérer un deuxième
rebond pour l'instant créer cette
confusion est peut-être cette inquiétude
et on le voit quand on interroge sur la
mutation du virus en fait on a des
réponses qui sont totalement
contradictoires
donc moi j'ai maintenant 3 toute petite
question précise la première on a
beaucoup parlé donc de mutation du virus
mais est ce que vous seriez nous dire où
en est l'état de nos connaissances quant
aux malades qui ont été symptomatique
vous disiez très justement qu'au début
il y avait peu de perdre à nos semis et
d'agouazi il y en a eu beaucoup plus
après est ce que ces malades là peut
avoir une évolution de leurs séquelles
par exemple atteint avis ou durablement
dans leurs terres danos me aggasy ça
c'est une première classe
la deuxième je ne crois pas que vous
ayez répondu à notre collègue rapporteur
bernard jomier quand vous avez dit de
manière très forte en matière
infectieuses il y avait une destruction
physique de l'organisation des maladies
infectieuses qui est à l'origine de
cette d'esprit destruction et pourquoi
enfin dernière question rapide lorsque
vous aviez été interrogé récemment pour
savoir ce que vous pensiez du port du
masque généralisée vous avez répondu je
ne fais pas de politique
et vous avez une phrase tout à l'heure
que j'ai trouvé forte aussi en dix ans
et l'intendance qui suit la décision
or on en a parlé ce matin avec le comité
scientifique on a eu l'impression qu'au
début il y avait pas de port du masque
généralisée parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
de masque maintenant il l'est parce
qu'on a des masques et je voulais savoir
ce que vous pensiez de ça je vous
remercie
olivier paccaud merci monsieur le
président professeur ce matin
effectivement les membres du conseil
scientifique comme l'a dit olivier henno
ont évoqué l'impréparation de notre
système médical pour faire face vous
même ça vient d'être redit dans votre
propos liminaire vous avez pointé du
doigt la désorganisation voire la
déstructuration programmée entre
guillemets de du système de recherche
épidémiologique de recherche
est ce qu'en fait c'est pas plutôt une
combinaison des deux qui aboutit à ce
que l'on peut considérer quand même
comme une hécatombe alors les chiffres
sont plus ou moins variable
vous avez dit vous même tout à l'heure
que c'était peut-être pas si dramatique
que ça par rapport à aux résultats 2015
de la grippe de 2015
je suis pas sûr que ça ne soit pas
dramatique quand même par contre ma
question elle va traiter de vous avez
auquel le benchmarking les résultats
français sont loin d'être brillant ya
pire il ya mieux
ce matin on avait eu quelques cas de
l'allemagne a quand même dix mille morts
mais il y a quelques jours dans cette
même dans ce même hémicycle nous avons
reçu les ambassadeurs de corée du sud de
taïwan et on a eu des chiffres qui sont
tout à fait éloquent sept morts à taïwan
346 en corée du sud
alors ma question c'est on a vu ce
qu'ils ont fait eux
vous d'après vous quand on veut éteindre
un incendie épidémiologique éviter
qu'ils se transforment en brasier
qu'est ce que l'on doit faire
immédiatement quand on a pas de vaccin
si monsieur le président à bas régime
universi mais simplement de questions
vous avez dit tout à l'heure c'est le
temps qui fait le tri et vous avez cité
beaucoup de papier c'est vrai que
vis-à-vis nous déjà mais je pense les
français c'est difficile quand même à
comprendre parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des
papiers et vous en avez d'ailleurs vous
l'avez dénonce et qui sont
malheureusement publiés et qu'ils sont
faux et je pense que la confusion dont
pas se parler ma collègue est quand même
extrêmement importante et que même s'il
faut attendre le temps c'est vrai que la
science a quand même parlé sur un
certain nombre de choses et comme
bernard jomier et d'autres moi je
regrette qu'il n'y ait pas de
confrontation parce que comme on n'a pas
de confrontation entre chercheurs
on vous voit dans les médias les uns se
re pour les autres contre et c'est vrai
que ce matin on parlait peut-être au
lieu du conseil scientifique est
peut-être une agence dédiée aux crises
et pas seulement d'ailleurs avec des
scientifiques mais aussi avec des
chercheurs des sciences humaines et
sociales
et s'il y avait peut-être cette agence
en france peut-être que ça permettrait
aussi aux français de mieux comprendre
de moins avoir peur et je voudrais avoir
un peu votre avis là dessus et puis la
dernière la deuxième question
ça rejoint d'ailleurs mon collègue david
assouline c'est on n'a pas parlé du
vaccin
quelle est votre position aujourd'hui
sur le vaccin merci david assouline où
la question est posée par un jeu lui a
soufflé une question qui me venait à
l'esprit mais non j'ai
deux questions brèves la première c'est
je reste perplexe parce que finalement
la polémique qui a fait connaître au
grand public
votre non monsieur le professeur vous
étiez déjà très connue des milieux qui
devait l'être qui était professionnel
c'est votre traitement
je ne comprends pas que six mois après
on en reste à
il ya les pour et les contre moi je pose
la question
six mois après même quand ça n'a pas été
autorisé à la prescription
je connais du monde qui parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de traitement se sont rués est
une façon ou d'une autre par ce
médicament
il n'y a pas eu de résultats aujourd'hui
on vous avez fait vos hôtes est sur une
centaine de personnes vous défendez qu'
il y avait des améliorations mais
maintenant six mois après c'est plus un
débat rien de probant enfin je comprends
pas ou sinon qu'est ce que vous dites à
monsieur macron vous lui dites que il
interdit et à tous ces scientifiques à
tous ces gens notamment le comité
scientifique qui disent que ce n'est pas
efficace faut aller au bout
vous les accusez de refuser un
médicament qui empêcherait des cas de
s'aggraver de soigner des français c'est
cessa six mois après c'est pas un débat
des pour et des contres moi je j'ai
beaucoup de critiques je suis critique
comme tout le monde
donc je prends je gobe pas tout ce que
nous dit le gouvernement les gens les
scientifiques
mais là à moins de me dire tiens coupe
l'eau qu'on veut que des français ne se
soigne pas et meurt je ne comprend pas
la nature du débat et ma conclusion en
question parce que la seule façon pour
moi de le comprendre c'est que derrière
le scientifique que vous êtes est le
pragmatique que vous êtes
il ya peut-être quelque chose qui vient
troubler c'est l'idéologie
qu'avez-vous de commun
pour faire tribune commune bientôt avec
monsieur onfray philosophe
qu'avez-vous de commun à dire ou sur la
pandémie
poux sur la société je ne comprends pas
merci jean sol épuisé
10dans monsieur le professeur j'ai
plusieurs questions comme l'ensemble des
français j'ai été confinés que
pensez-vous du confinement automne mis
en place dans notre pays
aurait-il pu être évité à l'instar
d'autres pays qui nous ont présenté
récemment mais leurs résultats
quel est votre avis sur la doctrine en
matière de masques qui s'est fait à
géométrie variable faut-il le
reconnaître qui est encore floue
aujourd'hui et dont certains remettent
en cause le degré de filtration dans
certains contextes
pensez vous que les moyens en matière de
recherche sont au rendez vous en france
je ne pense pas vous ne l'aviez déjà
exprimé lorsque nous vous nous avions
auditionnés vous savez cité l'exemple
tout à l'heure du nombre de scanners et
enfin est il possible selon vous de
raccourcir les délais pour réaliser les
tests aujourd'hui et surtout pour un
obtenir les résultats dans un délai
raisonnable merci merci avait coûté dix
minutes 10 minutes pour tout ça donc
s'il vous plaît le premier point qui est
qu'elle soit placebo le sport vous savez
c'est un vrai point c'est une occasion
que j'ai pas se discuter qu'elle
confesse j'ai discuté aussi bernard
henri lévy de de dire que c'est
dramatique d'apporter de l'espoir
je suis pas d'accord avec vous je pense
est dramatique d'apporter du désespoir
je pense et je continue à le penser je
continuerai à le penser
et l'effet placebo c'est effectivement
d'abord ça commence par apporter
l'espoir
donc il ya eu négligence de la
connaissance de l'effet placebo
scientifique j'ai perry fientes l'effet
placebo c'est un effet biologique que
l'on peut parfaitement noté avec les
moyens actuels de de radiologie qui
permet de voir qu'il ya des zones qui
sont éteintes ou qui sont ali mais quand
on vous savez quand on vous dit aux gens
qu'ils vont mourir on voit les zones
s'éteignent dans le cerveau ça s'appelle
l'effet nocebo et donc quand on dit ça
tous les soirs à la télévision ce qu'on
fait on crée de l'effet nocebo qui est
visible radiologiquement quand on donne
de l'espoir aux gens y compris avec un
effet placebo on voit les zones où cette
fixe et ce à six deux problèmes en droit
benzodiazépines dire ça calme les gens
donc ça je m'excuse et de la science
encore la deuxième chose c'est que
effectivement me souviens plus qui pose
la question on peut rebondir dessus il
ya une vraie question sur les séquelles
malheureusement on a commencé à
travailler dessus on a fait un papier
dessus qui est très impressionnant qui
montre que les zones où il ya des zones
qui ont un hypométabolisme derrière le
bulbe olfactif qui semble persister on
ne sait pas combien de temps elles vont
persister on sait pas ce qu'il guérira
et on sait pas ce qu'ils en protège mais
oui il ya des séquelles cérébrales
pendant un certain temps je sais pas
combien de temps plus que de séquelles
pulmonaires que l'on redoutait beaucoup
redoutaient beaucoup qui est beaucoup de
fibres hozjan a relativement peu mais il
ya des extinctions du métabolisme
cérébral qui qu'on perçoit et on n'a pas
suffisamment de recul pour savoir
combien de temps ça va durer
le lead et j'ai pas bien je vous leur
direz vous pensez vraiment que le
l'histoire de hydroxyque eurokin si vous
voulez et l'histoire de ce débat est un
débat franco français avec moi au milieu
et c'est parfait c'est simplement pas
vrai vous voyez ça dit si c'est vrai
c'est un débat mondial
vous vous rendez bien compte qu'on
comment vous pouvez penser qu'une bande
de polichinelle a publiée dans le new
england journal médecine et dans land 7
si on était pas on n'avait pas perdu
toute notion de base pour publier des
choses pareilles qui ont été rétractées
dans les trois mois je n'ai jamais vu ça
de toute l'histoire le métier j'ai
jamais vu ça c'est pas moi qui ai fait
ça c'est pas moi qui ai déterminer sa
donc arretez de croire que c'est une
histoire franco-française est un
phénomène beaucoup plus puissants que ça
qui est extrêmement qui est
international qui touche
il ya une partie qui a réagi d'une
certaine manière qui est l'europe de
l'ouest et une partie des états unis qui
a d'ailleurs les plus mauvais chiffres
mondiaux de gestion de la crise qui a
géré d'une certaine manière en courant
après une molécule nouvelle fait à
nouveau par des laboratoires qui
maintenant cours d'une certaine entre
manière après après la vaccination il ya
une autre partie qui était une partie de
gestion extrêmement pragmatique y
compris si vous avez vu les coréens
c'est un pragmatisme qui est totale donc
il y as we une manière pragmatique de
gérer chose qui est de détecter d'isoler
il ya des gens qui a des pays auxquels
on a réquisitionné des hôtels pour y
mettre les gens qui étaient positifs
quand il était positif de manière à
faire ce qu'on faisait avant avec le
lazaret et non pas faire ce qu'on a fait
avec le confinement qui est la
quarantaine
donc c'est des natures différentes ce
qui s'est passé dans la destruction et
la direction je suis d'accord que ça n'a
pas été volontaire il s'est trouvé que
il ya eu une époque qui est une époque
paradoxale qui était juste avant
l'épidémie de sida les gens disaient
maladies infectieuses c'est terminé donc
il y avait à paris à l'hôpital claude
bernard les gens ont travaillé sur les
maladies infectieuses et assez de
manière assez extraordinaire c'est au
moment où le sida est arrivé on a fermé
claude garde c'est en effet fermer
l'endroit dans lequel on pouvait
investir massivement pour pouvoir lutter
contre les nouvelles épidémies cas et ça
a été la pire épidémie du xxème siècle
assure et donc il ya une vraie il ya une
vraie question de remise en cause
est ce que vous vous considérez comme
est incompréhensible moi je comprends
bien c'est que quand les gens ont pris
probablement y compris d'ailleurs ont
pris une direction c'est très très
difficile de sortir du sentier dans
lequel on est rentré c'est très
compliqué de dire écoutez on s'est
trompé finalement c'est pas comme ça
qu'il fallait faire c'est compliqué pour
chacun d'entre nous mais c'est compliqué
pour le ministre c'est compliqué pour le
président la république c'est compliqué
pour delfraissy et ses prolongements
compliqué pour moi même si je suis pas
lucide de ce point de vue là parce que
je ne vois pas donc cesser c'est pas
encore une fois c'est ce qui s'est passé
et quand vous me dites ep tiens comment
ça se traduit moi je le trouve étonnant
que ce soit que les consignes de
maladies infectieuses dans l'assistance
publique de paris soit donnée par le
directeur sens unique de paris marseille
les consignes de mal à dire qu'ils ne
sont pas donnés par le dg de sang celui
de vincennes
donc si je peux vous dire que quand
j'étais jeune titulaire de chaire
défectueuse c'est lui qui disait
bautista qu'il faut faire c'était pas le
dg de l'assistance de paris c'est
étrange non enfin genre c'est bien c'est
un truc de professionnels la médecine je
m'excuse donc il y a une vraie question
bonjour je vous dis ce que je pense je
pensais moi je pensais qu'il allait
faire un haf x opole necker pasteur je
l'écris en 2003 mais à necker à pasteur
faire un bâtiment pour les maladies
infectieuses à necker soit juste à côté
de pasteur que les gens travaillent tu
es une antenne de la nds et maintenant
santé publique est là
il y aurait quelque chose qui pourrait
avoir une taille mondiale où il y aurait
des interlocuteurs soient capables de
tout faire ça c'était raisonnable
c'est ce que je pensais à l'époque et je
pense encore maintenant peut-être parce
que je suis incapable de changer de vie
c'est possible est ce que j'ai oublié
quelque chose vous posez la question de
dudu du confinement et et du masque cetc
des questions ceux qui sont extrêmement
auquel est extrêmement difficile de
répondre
il ya des gens qui commencent à étudier
ça à faire des études comparatives et
même ses études comparatives elles sont
difficiles à analyser parce que les
comportements sociaux dans les
différents pays sont pas les mêmes
donc le comportement social en italie et
en suède sait pas exactement mais en
particulier dans l'est les contacts
sociaux sont pas les mêmes et donc de
comparer l'effet du confinement sur
l'efficacité des mesures c'est quelque
chose qui est très complexe et moi je
pensais donc c'est ce que j'ai dit quand
j'ai rencontré le président je lui ai
dit moi il faut prendre je pense que le
rôle du politique c'est de prendre
toutes les mesures pour éviter
l'affolement la peur la peur est
terrible il faut éviter l'affolement
mais si ça donne l'effet inverse est
vrai alors c'est pas fonctionnel parce
que le confinement ça ça a été analysé
en italie en espagne sur des milliers de
tests de donneurs de sang 1
le confinement n'a pas protégé les gens
individuellement du risque d'infection
c'est à dire que les gens qui n'étaient
pas pour des raisons professionnelles à
part le métier de santé qui était pas
confiné tu es plutôt moins positif que
les gens confiné donc ya pas de
substrats scientifique individuel ce qui
ne veut pas dire que ce ne soit pas un
choix de société à un moment donné de
dire écoutez plutôt que tout le monde
soit folle et s'inquiètent et émigrent
si vous voulez il vaut mieux les
confiner donc je sais pas répondre à ça
et pour le masquer c'est pareil c'est
pas une vérité scientifique brutale il
ya une vérité scientifique brutale c'est
que quand vous êtes dans le personnel de
soins canton étant donné qu'on est à 30
40 centimètres des gens le risque de
contamination est plus important c'est
évident ça a été il a été démontré que
le masque de diminuer dans ces
conditions dans les autres conditions ça
n'a pas été démontrée ça peut pas l'être
donc c'est une question là aussi de
messages
social est-ce que ce message social est
utile j'ai pas d'avis je dirais plutôt
oui si vous voulez je sais pas s'il faut
être extrêmement punitifs sur quelque
chose comme ça mais je dirais que de le
fait de porter un masque si ça empêche
les gens de s'embrasser et quand ils
voient ou si ça leur permet de se faire
se rappeler qu'il ya quelque chose qui
circule c'est c'est pas on peut penser
que c'est raisonnable
voilà donc de permettre de conserver une
distance sociale sans se faire d'énormes
illusions sur le pouvoir c'est les mains
opel va faire attention il faut passer
dix fois vingt fois l'alcool sur les
mains par jour ça c'est vraiment c'est
les mains qui sont la clé mais si ce
message là permet de changer les
comportements
pendant cette période là je pense que
c'est intelligent et quant aux mutations
pour accéder à la question huit ans je
m'excuse si mutants dans votre dans
votre esprit ça veut dire plus méchant
je les dis que c'était plus méchants les
mutants ça veut dire que ça change
on a plutôt l'impression que les mutants
vont à sonder forme dégradée de la forme
initiale
c'est plutôt notre impression retrait
c'est très compliqué de deviner le
pouvoir pathogène d'un virus en voyant
ça c'est quinze personnes c'était
l'enfer mais globalement nous ça nous
appareil plutôt lié à des formes qui
sont moins bien sûr aussi sur une
régulation un peu de la parole
scientifique jeu mais mais mais mais
mais encore une fois je m'excuse de
france mais je veux d'abord je vous
appartient pas c'est à dire que ma
parole scientifique d'une parole libre
qui est garantie par la constitution et
par l'histoire du pays et elle s'adresse
d'une quantité de gens dans le monde
vous pensez que ce que j'ai dit est plus
conséquent seule la la prescription de
dix ans que la russie n'hésiteront
bessines vous vous trompez très très
lourdement
il ya un institut de sondage qui sont de
tous les médecins du monde pour leur
savoir quels sont pour leur demander
quels sont les médicaments qu'ils
prescrivent dans le corps vide
je pouvais à dire qu'il ya une une
influence sur intervenus en nombre de
gens considèrent que c'est une
thérapeutique essentiel qui est et qui
est énorme
vous verrez bien avec le temps là pour
l'instant encore une fois c'est pas moi
qui racontait les balivernes sur la sur
la toxicité d'un médicament qu'on ait
prescrit chez deux milliards de
personnes je raconte pas de balivernes
on verra bien
vous verrez bien pour l'instant c'est
les dossiers et les les
les publications sur l'usagé dans le
cycle enquiquinante que ça ça diminue en
30 et 50 % la mortalité sont en train de
s'accumuler pourrait bien vous arrête
pas de sortir il en sort tous les jours
vous allez c est ce qui concerne la
question de jean sol oui il manque des
scanners notamment l'osu l'avait dit et
on le partage on a déjà eu l'occasion
catherine déroché temps particulièrement
attentives à ce sujet là d'en parler
lors notamment des pelles fss quant aux
délais de test effectivement on constate
que iad et nous on en parle de stratégie
devrait peut-être évoluer écoutez nous
on n'a pas de problème de des lieux de
test le délai moyen de rendu chez nous
ces huit heures il n'y a pas de tests
qui se sont rendus en plus de 24 heures
pardon si c'est qu'ils ont des mains
chez eux en effet qui ont des résultats
très rapides mais tout le monde ne les a
pas les laboratoires d'analysés auquel
le lambda dans lequel on va n'a pas ce
type de machine mais je m'excuse mais
globalement pour pau pour clore puisque
c'est une question qui m'a été posée
c'est pourquoi finalement ces approches
ne se réconcilie pas des longues à venir
voir ce qu'on fait dans des salles ont
attesté 79 personnes sont venues voir ce
qu'on fait enfin je vous signale que le
ministre est passé à marseille il n'est
même pas venu regardez donc c'est pas
moi qui profite à personne et en
particulier je suis républicain donc je
respecte les gens qui sont aux affaires
je vous dis encore une fois nous jeux
publiés chiffres de ce que nous faisons
régulièrement et toutes les semaines
écoutez ça s'appelle le benchmarking ça
aussi si vous savoir comment on fait il
faut venir voir
moi je refuse personne d'aucun parti de
personnes sa dette égale et quant à
discuter avec les ans je discute avec
tous les joueurs intelligents
quel que soit leur bord merci merci bien
bah écoutez on va on va clore ce débat
en attendant le suivant en vous
remerciant n'y a pas eu de confrontation
mais il ya eu des échanges frontaux ce
qui était important merci